[Laughter]
hey everybody holy crap it's friday
again already i know i can't believe it
i like why is it so bright in here it
needs to it needs to stop
it's terrible
well it seemed like it fixed for a
second and then it [ __ ] up again oh
well not much i can do about it but hey
everybody
uh we're sleeping yeah pretty much what
the hell was that all about i fell
asleep you've been at the bar all day
yeah
tom's like the bar fly yeah
when did you yeah when did you get back
it was four thirty four seven i think it
was four thirty five i laid down and
[ __ ] fell asleep yeah
[Laughter]
went to the mexican restaurant too and
got a uh
got some mexican food got a chimichanga
yeah it was good
i actually
to the owner's son
he lifts and [ __ ] which we were talking
about
talking gym talk
yeah
he was he's only like 25 26
so you know
just just talking
just talking just how it is yeah
i decided i was going to give dominoes
another chance oh yeah did you get so
order it yeah yeah
i got a sandwich and a salad yeah they
did much better this time and honestly
since the last time they've actually
implemented that tracking device thing
okay so you can watch on the computer
like where exactly the car is
you know what i mean so they made the
[ __ ] it even says like if you go on the
domino's thing and you order it it even
says here's your order and then it's
like bake and then it says your order's
in the oven at whatever time and then
it's like now they're doing quality
check and now it's delivery and then the
little car comes toward your house yeah
so you can see like where the lady is
last time last time she ordered from
domino's
it never showed up and then she canceled
it and then i went outside and it was
sitting outside [ __ ] with ants all on
it well yeah because well i ordered it
and then it took like an hour hour and a
half and i was like [ __ ] and i kept
trying to call them and be like yeah can
i just cancel it and then finally we're
like [ __ ] it we're gonna go get chinese
food and then we went out the door to
get chinese food and like the dominance
like sitting on the
then i don't know how long it had been
sitting there but it had an answer
so i guess
they just saw it they just left it on
the doorstep
well i didn't know here's the thing
i'm kind of lying
i didn't realize there were ants i
picked it up
and then um
some of it was cold
remember that
yeah because it was i usually don't get
pizza i usually get like a salad and
like a like a regular garden salad and a
sandwich yeah it was cold so um
i put it in the refrigerator and then a
few minutes later looked in there and
the ants were in the bag yeah trying to
stay warm and i was i was like jenny
there's ants in this i think threw it
away because we had already eaten by
that point we already got chinese food
but well i said i'm gonna see what
happens because i didn't feel like going
anywhere to get food and domino's is
really close
and it had been a long enough time i
said maybe they got their [ __ ] together
because i think maybe what happened last
time was that
they didn't really have anybody to
deliver it
and so maybe they had one person and
they were kind of like run ragged and
they were just kind of like [ __ ] it
whatever and it was like taking so long
you know what i mean so but this time i
mean the food came in within 10 minutes
like they made it and
you know they put it in the oven and
they brought it and it was completely
fine like the lady came and dropped it
off
and like i said it took like 10 minutes
and it was good
so so like i said i'll give him another
chance i don't it's dominance isn't my
favorite but
like i said it's close
there's not really a lot of options
around here if you want something
delivered you know what i mean
like i think the chinese place holder
well you can get like doordash and stuff
like that but
there's not a lot of restaurants
really close by so i feel like doordash
might take a [ __ ] hour or something
like that
so
so i just called domino's because i had
too much [ __ ] to do and i didn't really
want to have to like go and drive and
get something so you know all right so
it looks like people everybody's all
showing up everybody's [ __ ] coming in
what are they saying jim
it's saturday with open line saturday
it's friday excuse me friday yeah
you don't know
what it is open lines friday
and uh anything look at book what is she
doing she's [ __ ] stepping on the back
of it with her feet
it's the funniest thing she wants
she'll go up to her toys and she'll grab
with her front foot throw it underneath
her back foot
and she can stand like stomps on it with
her back feet
i don't know why
it's fast
yeah like something like a rabbit she's
such a weirdo you know what she did the
other night i don't remember what time
it was i think it was like one or two in
the morning yeah
and i was sleeping
and all of a sudden i feel like because
my foot was sticking out the bottom of
the covers and all of a sudden i feel
boop like her little wet cold nose like
booped the bottom of my foot and it
scared me i was like what the [ __ ] like
i knew what it was but it scared me
and i was like what the hell and then
you know how we have those like laser
lights in the bedroom that look like a
galaxy like up on the ceiling we
obviously yeah so we obviously like turn
them off like before we get to sleep
because i can't sleep without much light
in the room but they turned on by
themselves so i guess pookie was like
warning me hey the light's on it's not
supposed to be on right
and i was like what that's [ __ ] weird
and then tom was like what the [ __ ] and
i was like your lights came on yeah and
then i noticed that because we can see
like his man cave is like down the hall
and the door was open and i could see
that the light that he had in there
which is kind of one of those like rgb
lights was like flashing like weird
colors and i was like what the hell is
going on in there
yeah so i think when i got up the next
morning
the clock on the it's weird because the
the little digital clock that i have on
the nightstand
it wasn't flashing
but the time said 2 30 a.m even though
it was 7 30 a.m yeah because i looked at
the clock i'm like what the [ __ ] i know
it's obviously not 2 30 a.m
and it was like really weird but i
thought it was weird because when the
light down the hall started flashing
like pookie was on the bed like you know
poking my foot and then she saw that and
she was like
and she jumped down and she ran over
there and like looked at it like what
the [ __ ] yeah she points to things mommy
look look look look
that's not right that's not correct yes
what's going on i'm scared
yeah she's smart cat
yeah she always like warns you if
something is different than usual right
she always kind of like weren't she's
like is this what is going on here
she'll like look at you like is it okay
lights are wrong yeah the lights are all
wrong yeah
they were wrong you're right
but it was just like her little nose is
like boop like on the bottom of my foot
hey
grandpa said uh bauhaus are playing in
detroit on september 16th
so you should do a road trip up there
just do a road trip up there
in detroit i just said
yeah
i'm not going there to see [ __ ] not go
to see them well i mean we could go up
there and like do other things as well
and then see them too
but i wonder how long it would take to
drive to detroit foreign
about nine ten hours
well that's not bad yeah
i've driven to wait well hold on it's a
double shift so 16.
oh okay that's six that's so much
i've driven to i've driven from orlando
to
baltimore before
how long did that take
i want to say it took 10 hours maybe it
was longer than that
i used to be able to ride 12 to 16 hours
like it was like it was nothing but you
know [ __ ] man nowadays when you get
older you get [ __ ] you get kind of
soft you're like yeah i want to [ __ ]
ride that amount of time
well you get lazy it's like so much work
yeah it's a lot of work i'm tired yeah
i'm old now i'd better jump on a plane
and be there in a couple hours
um honestly i don't really like being in
the car i don't really like driving but
i would rather do almost anything than
like flying a [ __ ] flying a [ __ ]
airplane i hate flying
she's like [ __ ] i hate flavor i mean i
will if i had to absolutely but i really
hate it i love it i really hate it yeah
it just gives me horrible stress
and i don't it didn't used to but i did
it a bunch of times and it just got
worse and worse every single time dj
maniac yeah go to detroit and get shot
in the dick by robocop
get shot
right by robocop sure why not yep um
zach is saying that he had to order from
panera because that's healthier i
actually really like panera but i don't
know where the closest one
there used to be one fairly close to our
old house but i don't know
uh where the closest one is around here
pretty much what's all that's close to
our house is
the japanese restaurant the chinese pla
take out
a like breakfast and lunch place that
closes at two
an ice cream and coffee place and
yeah and publix that has you know they
have a deli and stuff but that's about
it i mean there's probably other stuff
like close but
like i said if you want delivery
even from doordash or something like
that it would probably take a really
long time if you order from somewhere
farther away i would imagine
tom has morning sickness
[Laughter]
are you pregnant tom no what have you
been trying to tell me nothing i'm not
pregnant
you're not pregnant what is she doing
what is she doing there what are you
doing sweetie what's up you want to be
on the show yeah she realized that the
show just started she's very mad at me
because oh hey finally it like it
that sun stopped glaring in the window i
hate that um
it's been like so [ __ ] windy today i
can't even
it's i feel like something it sounds
like something is hitting the window
but i can't imagine what it could be
because there's no trees right there
is there it's at the other end of the
house
oh it sounds like it's right there
because i was like i'm in here working
i'm like jesus christ it might be that
uh weather stripping
i guess
because i was like it sounded like a
tree but this the two windows of this
office are right over the garage which
is right over the driveway there's no
trees that are close enough to go check
it knock into it try that weather stream
but it's really i was really really loud
it sounded like a [ __ ] tornado out
there today jesus christ i don't know
what the [ __ ] jesus christ
uh grant i could show you detroit the
third person i guess crackheads shouting
at the sky bloody needles in the park
packs of ghetto dogs roaming in the
streets block after block of burned out
homes that sounds kind of fun
sounds kind of fun you already dealt
with that today
i was there at the biker bar i already
dealt with that today
oh i haven't heard this story yet what
happened i was just going to ask you
what happened what's shaking down at the
oasis
i just [ __ ] pull up i'm saying hi to
all the regulars and [ __ ] put my gear
up
and some chick [ __ ] comes in there
and and can i sit down here and i was
like yeah okay if you must i'm looking
at it
which is probably what i would have said
yeah
yeah okay i hate to ask you but i have a
drink here we go
so i've just i said yeah go ahead and
get her a [ __ ] beer
oh you sucker and it was a beer after a
beer [ __ ] three of them and she
didn't make any goddamn stance every
time she opened her mouth it didn't make
any sense she had she was something
wrong with her she had i think she had
paranoid paranoid schizophrenia
uh she thought putin was it was after
putin was after her
um i'm trying to think what else she
said
the hell's angels were after her
the wendigo was after her probably no
not the one ago yeah
and then uh
that was about it i hate to make fun of
mental health yeah she looked like she
hadn't bathed in a day or two
and you bought her beers
yeah i was just kind of babysitting her
a little bit
but the the the the bartender there i
don't think she charged me
oh okay
you know what i mean and i don't think
she charged me she knew i was trying to
keep this on kind of placate her yeah
because if you said no she probably
would have like [ __ ] wigged out yeah
i guess she goes who is that she's i
don't know
she's got something wrong with her you
know that's just in between you know she
goes and she's we mean she's something
wrong with her she's well she says
putin's after this it sounds like
paranoid schizophrenia because oh my
daughter has that and i said yeah that's
what it is and she likes yeah she she's
a little bit handicapped and then i said
on the side she said she was a woman of
the trade so i said she's oh she's one
of those
she's a hook-up yeah but she didn't so
she was she was trying to get some [ __ ]
out of here she didn't make a she didn't
make a play i don't know it might have
just been crazy she might have been
crazy all right
and then um
about two drinks into it says you don't
steal do you and she's like no i don't
steal i tried to entertain her but it
really didn't
anything she said it didn't make sense
and she laughed and anything i told her
she didn't understand she still laughed
when i came back she was gone
she didn't take any of your [ __ ] did she
take your wallet no no i just didn't
want her to take my tablet all the
glasses
and uh
bartender was like where'd she go i was
like i don't know i think she's in the
bathroom and she goes i don't know she
says no she's not here because there's
only five people in the damn place
at that time
and so she was left so she like slipped
out with anybody seeing her that's crazy
yeah like a ninja
like maybe that's her maybe she's a
ninja maybe that's her cover yeah that
she's like a crazy paranoid
schizophrenic who hangs out in bars on
the day no
maybe she's a supernatural creature of
some kind
i says i sense a horror story no
no i'm getting ideas
[Laughter]
that would actually that would be a good
opening for a story actually
she had teeth so
that was you know what i was actually
going to ask you that exact question
like how many teeth did you know she had
teeth okay she had teeth she had teeth
so she didn't have methamphetamine i
don't think it was meth it was just
mental illness
which like i said it's sad but it's like
i don't know look for a long time like i
grew up in daytona which isn't you know
it isn't it's kind of rednecky it's not
quite as rednecky as this but areas of
it are rednecky and for a long time i
didn't have a car so i had to take the
bus
and the thing about daytona and volusia
county in general and florida in general
really if you don't have a car you're
kind of [ __ ] you're crazy because the
bus systems are
spotty at best
and most people have cars because
everything's so spread out
um so it takes like an hour and a half
to get anywhere you want to go one and
two the only people who ride the bus are
people who can't drive for whatever
reason because they're too old or
they're too mentally handicapped or
they've had too many dui's
or something yeah so um when you ride
the bus it's always
uh a thrill yeah to see who's gonna
end up sitting next to you and what
they're gonna smell like
and
what they're gonna
talk to you about because of course
they're gonna talk to you they're not
just gonna like leave you alone you're
right you know what i mean
so i think it's funny when after a while
i was just like you know what i think
i'm just gonna walk everywhere even if
it's like eight miles
yeah i think it's funny when i
hear people comment about well they need
public transportation public
transportation and you look at who is
who's talking it's somebody from europe
or
boston and you just start laughing and
you go like yeah i'd love to see you
ride public transportation down here but
like i said the only the reason that
public transportation down here is like
that
is because everything's so spread out
and most people
don't use it right you know what i mean
so you only get kind of like you know
the dregs i hate to say that because
that's like sounds judgmental but it's
people that otherwise can't drive for
whatever reason yeah
so
you know
and it's not oh and it's not always bad
like sometimes it's just people that are
blind or whatever it's like you know not
everyone was or they're just old you
know and they can't drive anymore so
it's not like you know everybody on
there is a nightmare but i remember one
guy and he was actually kind of famous
in daytona i think his name was jerry
i'm sure he's probably dead by now
but he used to ride the bus all the time
and
he always
had
a bunch of
towels
like wrapped around his head like a
turban like a bunch of them like a whole
bunch of towels wrapped around his head
and then like around his like midsection
he had you know those um like plastic
visors you know like you get them from
bars and [ __ ] like that at spring break
or whatever he had like a whole shitload
of those he had like whole connect
collection
the weird thing about it was that even
though he obviously looked like a crazy
person because he had a towel
uh
turban on and was covered with
plastic uh visors
if you talk to him he actually seemed
normal
he didn't smell too good gotta say he
didn't look
homeless and so he didn't look dirty you
know what i'm saying
and like some of the bus driver because
some of the people like what's that
dude's deal and they're like we don't
think he's homeless because a lot of
times like he they pick him up from the
same place and they assume that it was
his apartment or he lived there but they
didn't really know why he went around
like that like if he maybe he thought
that the
i don't know maybe maybe he was
protecting his head from something or
maybe he had like a giant unicorn horn i
don't [ __ ] know
i'm just making stuff up but um
they even did i remember they even did
like an article about him in the paper
because i guess everyone was kind of
curious like what is this dude's deal
like i said it would be different if he
just came across as
you know an obvious crazy person
but he didn't yeah and i'm pretty sure
he wasn't homeless either tyler says if
i met a schizophrenic ninja and tell
everybody about it yeah she just
she she definitely had some kind of
schizophrenia but she was also
hitting around she wanted coke and she
wanted she wanted uh she wanted to know
if i had any meth
and you know
and uh then yeah i got some right here
in my pocket yeah
and take all you want she kept sniffing
all kind of myth sniff and hurting her
[ __ ] her nasal patches were all
[ __ ] up but then she wasn't making any
sense
you
just and she was just
she thought putin was after her
um
what else did she say
that they didn't love america that was
another thing she was highly patriotic a
highly patriotic crackhead
that
the problem was is the problem with all
this [ __ ] is that they don't love
america
and then um see what else she said it
was it was kind of funny you know
just didn't know if i could turn my back
on her
but she ain't weigh anything you know
she's like five two it didn't weigh
anything yeah she tried to think she's
popping one yeah
it's just she was just like i said i
hate to be like that but
that's the thing it's like i hate to be
like that because a lot of the times
they can't help it you know what i mean
but
on the other hand you don't really want
to deal with it either because i don't
really honestly to be honest with you i
don't when i go out in public i don't
even like to deal with normal people too
much um
so if somebody has like some problems
and they're gonna be like all up in your
grill i'm really not having that i
really don't like that i asked her a
bunch of questions and each each answer
had nothing to do with the question that
i asked her the only the only thing
that she answered was this is what's
your name and she goes rebecca that was
it
other than that i would be like you know
just any question was you know like so
what do you do for living then she would
just tell me about [ __ ] this
you know there's there's nothing nothing
made any damn sense
she's doing pokey
it's just kind of bartender's like you
all right you go yeah i'm okay so i just
kind of babysit
and
that yeah that was amazing she slammed
two or three drinks
which i guess i didn't i didn't pay for
and then she walked out because she was
a funny one i asked if i could film her
she wouldn't let me
i was gonna put her on the show well
yeah that's gonna make her even more
paranoid yeah because she's gonna she's
gonna think you're working for like her
persecutors she said it wouldn't it
never works out that's what she said
what she doesn't show up on film
no she is a supernatural creature i told
you it never works out she goes on i
don't i don't like that it never works
out that's what she said
is it okay maybe she just meant she
doesn't look good on camera yeah yeah
maybe maybe because that sounds like
something a woman would say like don't
kill me it doesn't work it never works
out yeah i know that feeling yeah but
you know what i mean it's just kind of
like
i don't know it's
[Laughter]
she's wearing them [ __ ] little
she was basically barefoot foot with
them flip-flops
and i said how big are your feet because
they're size six and this is those are
little feet and she goes yeah then she
liked that and i sent her that's the
same size feeders those are little feet
and she's like yeah
they are little so she laughed about
that for a while they're little people
you just gotta you just have to keep
them entertained it's like children you
know
yeah well you don't want them going too
far off into crazy town no because you
never know what they're going to do you
know what i mean you never know what's
going to happen which like i said that's
really scary so you said the thing
somebody said that their daughter had
that
yeah bar says my daughter has that
that's what they do and she's like she
they can't help it no i know she's off
she's off her medication that's what the
doctor that's what the bartender i saw a
documentary a while back about
schizophrenia and for me i remember
seeing that and i'd be like oh my god
that's got to be one of the worst things
that happened to a person and a lot of
times it doesn't like it and it just
i think part of it is genetic but
it can kind of like hit you
just at random and a lot of times it
doesn't manifest until you're in like
your 20s yeah
and then it'll just suddenly i'm like oh
my god that's going to be the [ __ ]
worst yeah tell the buddies this isn't
like she's showered because yeah she
goes they come off that medication and
they they forget to shower they'll go
like that for days
yeah and then you know well they have
like like you said they have delusions
that's a very common thing where they
think like the government or somebody
like that is
monitoring them or remember that
remember that girl that is she korean or
i think she was korean
she had that youtube channel do you know
who i'm talking about it's pretty famous
korean i'm pretty sure she was a korean
girl and she had a youtube channel
and it's on all of those kind of like
youtube creepiest i think we even talked
about it on our creepy youtube video
show
where she filmed herself all the time
and she would never leave her apartment
and she thought everybody was like she
would make like all these signs and she
thought like people were coming in there
and like moving stuff around and all
these people are like coming together
and stuff now she was actually on
the people that were coming in there
were you know
people from like the social services and
they were coming to check on her to make
sure she was eating and doing okay um
but she got paranoid and she thought
they were coming in there stealing
things or
you know doing stuff to her while she
was sleeping and all this stuff but she
filmed herself
like all the time yeah like even like
sleeping and
it was like it's really it was creepy
but it was like really sad yeah you know
what i mean she did have like i said
social services did were aware of her
and did come over and check on her so
she did
have people looking after her
um but
she wasn't dangerous or anything like
that i don't think
um she never really seemed to leave her
apartment really she seemed to be afraid
to so they kind of had people come in
and like check on her every so often to
make sure she was all right which is
nice
but
it's just it's sad it's like really sad
and scary i wanted to get the damn i
wanted to get a damn um
i wanted to get a [ __ ] video of her
because to show her on the show
people probably have been tripped out
i got
and she reminded me of this one
yeah that's what grantham said you
should have brought her home and put her
on the show no no no no yeah that's not
too she was fair
she was feral
okay she was how pissed off would i been
you come home at 4 30 you're like roll
it up and you're like
i brought this schizophrenic crackhead
home with me yeah
she was one of the please entertain her
she was one of these which like i said
not judging of this thing
please leave me alone
for stalking me and reporting me
where you at right now sir officer where
are you at i'm not an officer okay where
am i
[Music]
yourself you was talking to yourself i
was trying to make sure you didn't need
help
[Music]
i didn't save me from nothing because
herself y'all may be [ __ ] i'm gonna save
this one for night i don't know
tonight what's your name i don't know
[Music]
do we need to call it i don't know
oh
like i said she's one of those i mean
she's obviously that girl isn't it crazy
birthday yeah
and like i said i think a lot of times i
can't help it right so it's just kind of
sad but like i said
dealing with that all the time would you
really probably wear you out it would
wear me out
you know
nothing made any sense that that
every question i asked asked her
came back
like that gibberish
i want yeah
well they i think they kind of have
their own narrative going on in their
head
so it probably makes sense to them to
some degree
yeah
maybe no i don't know i don't think
or they're not really thinking they're
not thinking about it
maybe yeah i don't know it probably
makes sense to them there you go yeah
yeah her name is freedom
[Laughter]
murder hornet asks how's the uk hot as
[ __ ] here
and mega said we've had a warmish day
it wasn't today uh in florida was
actually not too bad i think it was
pretty mild
but it was super windy holy crap it was
windy yesterday though it rained
all day
off and on like it rained and then it
stormed and then it rained it was kind
of cloudy
i like that though i don't like it when
it's really sunny
jeffy art said i feel so sorry for her
yeah it's like because like i said they
can't help it they're not being that way
on purpose
and
i don't know so in a way it's like i
feel kind of bad like kind of making fun
of them but because they can't really
help being like that but well the one
that i showed you i think i think that
was myth i think
maybe although she looked pretty healthy
and clean she didn't look like gross or
[ __ ] anything like that when i was
talking about was kind of like that but
it wasn't meth it was it was it was
schizophrenia although there might be
both
because she was looking for meth and she
was looking for cocaine
and she said she was a woman of the
trade a woman of the tree yeah and and i
was like huh
really i mean you just assumed that it
meant that maybe maybe she meant
something else i don't know what it
meant something else assumed she's
talking about she was she was for sale
but she never made any maybe she's a
welder yeah
she's a welder by day and a dancer by
day and i was like
she's a maniac maniac you know what i
mean movement of the trade that probably
hasn't showered in three or four days no
thanks
but uh you know well what'd she look
like otherwise how old was she uh 25 i
think 25 22 okay she was visiting she
was on the level of that one that i just
showed you oh okay she didn't look she
didn't look bad she just was not
not all that and she's not all there
crazy yeah crazy yikes
somebody said the uk had snow last week
that's crazy
yeah
in florida
if we have cold days
at all
um
there'll be a couple cold days in
january february
but
after that and sometimes you get some
cold nights in march
but once april comes along nope
pretty much up in the 70s you're not
getting cold [ __ ] anymore makes me so
sad
but then i was thinking well
i don't know i just gotta wait out
[ __ ] summer soon it'll be soon it'll
be fall again
i just gotta go into like hibernation
mode i guess
[Laughter]
yeah right mm-hmm
you seem kind of like uh
yeah it's not totally wick up yet you
seem kind of like out of it not totally
awake yet
i can't believe you fell asleep yeah
fell asleep
fell asleep when i was drinking
what time did you get up this morning it
was kind of late i thought about ten
yeah i thought it was 10 i woke up at
six for gray's sake like i woke up and
then i was like well
i always wake up between six and seven
because i always have to go to the
bathroom and then i was just kind of
like should i get up or should i just
lay here but then i lay here and i was
like oh i'm kind of comfortable but i'm
like no i'm not really that comfortable
because i have to pee so it's like i
always have to get up and i'm just like
[ __ ] i'm getting up it's like
sun comes up i can't sleep once the sun
comes up
sucks
i probably need some more drink i would
imagine
see if the ice maker's making i still
had to fill all that [ __ ] up i only put
i deliberately only put like two small
scoops in there okay so i could let it
you know whenever we started the show 35
minutes ago
although i made the drink like more than
that like 45 minutes ago something like
that
um let's see what is everybody saying
yeah that's
that's the thing you always kind of like
encounter and i kind of feel like maybe
it happens
it probably happens a lot around here
because this is kind of out in the rural
probably the same kind of [ __ ] that
happens in daytona this is why i never
wanted to go anywhere in daytona
i didn't want to hang out any biker bars
or stuff like that or like i said i was
kind of like forced to ride the bus and
you'd always get like some weirdo like
sitting next to you like
that smelled like pee and
was talking about [ __ ]
i don't know i don't know what and it's
just i don't know so depressing so
depressing
but
i'm glad i don't have to do it but
that's why finally i saved up and bought
a car because i was like [ __ ] this i
can't do this [ __ ] anymore but i did
take the bus for a really really long
time i didn't actually buy a car until i
was
25 26 something like that so prior to
that i had to take a bus or walk
everywhere
so
you know because
i mean the bus is terrible the bus is
terrible
and i'm sure it's worse than other
places i didn't mind like big cities
that you know that a lot of different
people take public transportation like
new york and washington dc it's like
yeah there's crazy people on there but
there's enough normal people on there
that it kind of like balances out so
it's like less likely because there's
like a bunch of normal people on there
too so it's not like
i feel like the ones in daytona
so few quote unquote normal people take
them that the likelihood is quite high
that when you're taking the bus in
volusia county or something that some
[ __ ] weirdo is gonna end up like
sitting by you you know what i mean
like some weird
we had like a lot of drunks too because
there would be you know dudes that had
gotten duis and got their license taken
away
and so they had to take buses out to
oh and also one of the routes that i had
used to have to take to work
was the same route that went out to the
prison
so you would get you could however often
like once a week or once a month or
whatever it was you would get like all
the family members going out to visit
the people at the prison so you got that
too but you know
there was always that
um zach says okay this panera is hitting
the spot and i'm already feeling good
after all the crap i've been eating
lately
i mean as like i said i'm kind of a big
fan of panera i used to eat there all
the time there used to be one by my
house in daytona and i used to eat there
all the time
did they still have that uh what do they
call it the frontega chicken or whatever
do they still have that sandwich because
i think that was their best one they had
that one and they used to have this was
a long time ago they used to have one
that was a portabello
mushroom panini
and i always i liked that one a lot too
but i don't know if they have that
anymore and their tomato soup is really
really good
dj maniac my mom always said there's
always one weirdo on the bus i never
found him yeah you know what that means
you know what that means
i hate to ride next to traffic
i mean i don't know
a lot of times like i said i kind of
wish there was better public shrimp
because one of the coolest things about
um like i said visiting big cities in
the us or being in the uk
was that
when i was in wales like i could get up
in the morning walk a mile down the
street and get on a train and go
anywhere the [ __ ] i wanted to in europe
and i just thought that was so [ __ ]
cool
like it was so easy
like i don't really
it's nice having your own car but i
don't really enjoy driving you know what
i mean and especially in
around this area like the orlando area
specif specifically
i-4
it's better than it was uh because
they've widened it and they actually
improved it and stuff but it still kind
of blows it's like everybody that drives
on there is a crazy person
and they seem to be in a competition to
see how fast and recklessly they can
drive and how many people they can kill
they're not american
yeah well i kind of feel like maybe they
kind of feel like they're in like grand
theft auto yeah um
in real life
so every time we have to get on i-4 i'm
just kind of like he always i'm like i'm
not driving [ __ ] that and so like but
then i'm just kind of like looking down
at my lap going i'm just like not even
gonna look at all the [ __ ] cars
because
every night every time we go out to the
club
there's always at least
two or three people
drag racing yeah on i-4 it's ridiculous
and i'm just kind of like do you realize
everybody's going 80 90 100 miles an
hour i was like do you realize what
would happen if one of it just please
please stop it i just i don't understand
like why we're doing that and they're
not great drivers they think they are
but they're not even if you are why just
there's no reason knock it off they'll
come up behind you going about 110 115
and pass you
like i'm already going 80
and then they'll run right into the back
of a traffic jam that you could see a
mile away
but then they try to fight to get around
a damn traffic jam and i'm like where is
that where do you think you're going
we're all stuck here too yeah you're not
magic you can't [ __ ] float
so
cracks a hell of a drug i guess yeah
it's all i can think of or like why the
[ __ ] there's no thinking ahead
and like i said i don't really
understand
like i understand assertive driving but
i don't understand aggressive driving in
the sense that you're driving you're
taking stupid chances when there's no
reason to yeah you know what i mean it's
like look we're all going downtown we're
all going to the same place we'll all
get there
in you know whatever the time period is
just calm down yeah i mean there's no
reason to like kill a whole bunch of
people on the way there
calm down
i don't understand okay so the show's
been on
is friday
we got pookie stretched out over there
is she stretched yeah look good
i turned around and she's like
it's the tom's apocalypse edition
i couldn't think of anything but then i
thought if you're like uh april tom's
day and i was like i'm going to start
making puns i'm going to start making
puns with tom's name look at her look at
her and that was the first thing i
thought i got her hands oh my gosh
she's a stretch loaf
yeah stretch love why are you stress
loafing she's like because i'm
comfortable why are you looking at me
funny okay
is everything all right
all right thank you jeffy art oh what
did he say uh jenny good call and
extraordinary wasn't that delightful i
loved that movie so much
last night uh i bought it on amazon for
five dollars and loved it can't believe
it's not that well known what a gem yeah
everybody i reviewed a movie called
extraordinary it's an irish horror
comedy and it is
delightful
got another super chat it's on shutter
actually
i watched it and i reviewed it that's
right speaking of gta a show on that
lawyer from uh florida jack thompson who
made it his uh raison d'etre to get the
games banned would be amazing oh
that is a good idea so we tried to get
grand theft auto band yeah
i remember like yeah i remember that
they didn't understand
that's the thing it's like
they're just games yeah
i'm i'm not a big fan of this kind of
like oh games made people do that [ __ ]
it's like you know people are gonna do
bad [ __ ]
you know are people that already have a
propensity to do that kind of [ __ ]
attracted to those kind of games
probably
um but i don't think the game caused
them to be like that like if they were
just like a normal nice person
beforehand and then they played gta and
they'd be like i'm gonna kill everybody
i'm gonna drive all over this [ __ ]
that's yeah i don't think it happens
most of the dudes that play video games
don't have the physical strength to do
most of the [ __ ] they're showing in
those games anyway climb up the side of
buildings honestly well they say the
same thing about horror movies and [ __ ]
like that it's like look i've been
watching horror movies since i was
[ __ ] seven years old i've never
killed anybody that i know of and it's
just kind of like
honestly you watch it it's like escapism
yeah you know and a lot of times you get
like a lot of the same
you know rage and [ __ ] like that if you
want to call it that you can get it out
watching horror movies or playing video
games or doing something like that and
you don't do it in real life i i think
it's like better to have that grand
theft auto [ __ ] the you're the main
character look like you weigh about a
[ __ ] 150 pounds and just run up and
just beat anybody's ass easily
you know it doesn't really work it
doesn't work that way
if you weigh 150 pounds and you run up
on a dude who's looking somewhere
between 150 and 170 pounds
you're gonna be fighting a dude all day
and you're gonna get hurt during that
it's not gonna be easy
you can't just run up beat somebody's
ass like on a video game
not a real person
tyler says you guys should probably do a
show on road rage incidents yeah that
would actually probably be a good show
like give me do i have a piece of paper
over there in a pen there's a little
piece of paper by my phone
and then i meant to put it over here no
i got a pen i just need a i got a pen i
need paper
there's like a piece of paper by the
phone
yeah there we go that was like some
notes i was writing for them for a
graphic design job i was talking to
somebody on the phone earlier i'm
writing everything down really quick all
right so road rate whoops
oh and of course this pen doesn't work
okay there it goes okay road
rage okay so i'll put that in the next
poll because the poll for next week's
show has already gone up but i'll put
that in the next poll because that is
actually a good idea
um
camp guy says the older i get the slower
i drive yeah i mean i don't drive slow
i'll admit i do speed but
um i don't take dumbass chances and i
don't like
honestly i'm gonna go the route that has
the least amount of cars on it so
because i don't want to be around people
i don't want to be around other cars
because
you know the chance just goes up
that
bad shit's gonna happen
um let me see
do
yeah mango is also saying it's an
awesome movie it was so good i can't
believe it's more people should like see
it i'm glad i'm glad that shutter
finally added it i heard about it
it came out in 2019 i heard about it
about a year ago because it kept turning
up on
like a lot of critics like horror
critics like best movies of the year
lists and i was like man i got to see
that and i wrote it down on my list but
i was like man this is like a [ __ ] to
get hold of but then like shutter
finally added i was like woohoo i've
been wanted to see this for like a
[ __ ] year and a half and i finally
watched it and it is it is so good it's
so
funny like if you like shawn of the dead
then you will totally be into this you
you'll totally be into it it is it's so
so lovable and delightful and funny i
loved it
um and i i kind of feel like everybody i
i didn't really see any negative reviews
of it like pretty much everybody thought
it was hysterical it's cereal
brad says i'm a schizophrenic pyromaniac
alcoholic ninja it's true
[Laughter]
mango says we've had some classic road
rage killings in the uk yeah i remember
writing about a couple of those
i can't remember what the case was but i
remember writing about one of those for
my book but yeah
i feel like
we probably have more of them in the u.s
i mean i'm sure we do
but
this is [ __ ] up but because we have so
much [ __ ] up stuff happen and the
country's so big that you probably don't
even hear about them most of the time
yeah so you probably don't even i mean
in florida we'd probably only hear about
the ones that happened in like central
florida
we wouldn't hear about ones that
happened in other states unless they
were really [ __ ] up and egregious you
know a lot of stuff just goes kind of
like it never appears on the radar
because it's just a humdrum
like when the dude ate the other dude's
face in the middle of the road we heard
about that
the zombie does
that was during the [ __ ] beginning
yeah because that's yeah right because
obviously that was never really
they never really [ __ ] answered the
questions behind that one i think that
one is what they would call bath salts
which is uh there was someone
the chinese were smuggling drugs into
the united states under other names
like one of them that they would smuggle
drugs in was like potpourri
all right where you when you got it it
was just look like potpourri and they
would sell it
at
dime stores two-bit dime stores a drug
user knew what it was though you could
you could take that potpourri and smoke
it and it laced it with some kind of
chemical
smoking pokemon
high as [ __ ]
they had another one that was like sold
as bath salts
but it had some kind of chemical in it
you smoked that it made you [ __ ]
super high
so it was just kind of a crooked way of
getting it into the country
under another name
and you had to know
i guess the vendor had to know what it
was said look smoke dead
because that's bath salts because yeah
that's bad salt smoke it you know what i
mean it smoked that to get higher trust
me and it was always some kind of real
cheap
designer drug out of china
that was
you
you could probably isolate the molecule
but you still wouldn't really really
know what it was it'd be
something along the lines of like
synthetic
some kind of like synthetic [ __ ]
crack or like a synthetic
what's that other [ __ ] that they were
[ __ ] sending in here
kind of like
kind of like methamphetamine but a
cheaper synthetic version of it
and i think that's what the what the
zombie killer was although he didn't
kill that guy
he just found two dudes out in front of
the damn
hospital in between concrete barriers
naked they're on the security camera
naked laying next to each other fighting
and one one of them eats the other
dude's face off the white dude in the
black dude
salt and pepper team
salt and pepper team the sex got [ __ ]
violent they could have used some salt
and pepper when he hit his face
yeah
and they were two bombs you know
they both lived
but they caught parts of it on video bum
style bump it was it was it was bomb
violence sexual sexual bone violence
weird [ __ ]
i mean
and then they this like florida man is a
meme for a reason yeah you know
so that was all over the news for a
while you know and then it just kind of
calms down could it not be
and uh
the state government said well his his
uh
drug tests came back negative you know
see that's the last i heard yeah did he
just like want to eat someone's face
just for the [ __ ] of it or what well now
what it was is that whatever drug it was
it didn't show up it doesn't show up on
those tests because that molecule was
made
to elude all the drug tests
to get around the drug test so it's not
the same as selling drugs it's not an
identifiable drug that's been banned
so you know the chinese know what
they're doing
but it was something that they smoked
that
make you go crazy makes you want to eat
someone's face off yeah there's
something like a [ __ ] yeah it was
something like flocka
which flocka might might have been
flocka
i'm not sure exactly what flakka looks
like
flocka might come in a bunch of yeah i'm
not i'm not down with uh with the all
the drugs
yeah appearances these days slack will
make you repeat yourself
there's a actually on on youtube because
you watch these sometimes aren't there
like a lot of shows of videos of like
people on flocka yeah i'll show some
flock of videos granthar said oh they
identified another serial killer this
week from genealogy dna see i thought
they'd be doing a lot that a lot the
day's end killer who killed several
women in indiana in the 1980s dude died
10 years ago
see i had kind of hoped that
all of that would happen that they would
like catch i kind of remember hearing
about that case actually
um
yeah all right hey tayla happy friday
y'all
uh
dj maniac says i watched the jimmy
jimmy
savile right yeah yeah
doc on netflix last night he was one of
the uh topics that was in the patreon
poll as well so i don't know if we're
doing a show about him next week but
he's like ugh i need two showers after
that
i know a little bit about the case but
not a great deal but i did put it in the
polls so we'll see if it wins we might
do a show about that here's a good
flocka video
[Laughter]
he's having a good time
[Music]
where's your shoe dude what where's your
shoe what happened
[ __ ]
hey dude guess what
dude seriously
he's doing like a charlie chaplin [ __ ]
what'd you do last night man what what'd
you do last night
what'd you do
hey
this isn't good for my business
this is bad for
business is it
he's looking for you taylor
he's calling you taylor
[Music]
sir i'm gonna have to ask you to leave
the property yeah let's see how well
that works
is that too much ass
that's flagger
have you ever been on youtube
you left your money back here go back
here
please make this
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] on the ground
[ __ ]
there's a couple other flocking ones
i'll show you another one drugs are bad
okay have fun drugs are bad okay
they're not all bad yeah just that one
just that one i mean
you're gonna take that uh john smith
says the most famous road rage killer in
the uk i think was kenneth uh noyee noye
i guess how you pronounce that he had
previously been acquitted of killing a
police officer by a self-defense claim
but that's something i can't believe he
actually got away with that and killed a
young guy in a road rage incident [ __ ]
i'm gonna have to look that up okay i'm
gonna look that case i'm writing [ __ ]
down writing [ __ ] down i wrote down zack
i wrote down video game controversy so
don't worry that'll be in the next poll
so we're gonna talk about kenneth
noyen
i like when you guys give me ideas for
stuff because like i said i run out of
ideas to like put in the polls sometimes
you know what i mean
uh
tammy says have you seen boondock saints
one or two i saw the first one uh i
actually really liked the first one a
lot but i haven't seen
the second one
uh zach says random as [ __ ] but cream
soda yes or no me no yeah yes yeah he
loves cream said i don't hate it
but
if given the choice meh
it's not really my thing
i love root beer though
root beer is good
i'm not a big soda person
you know
i know i like
you like money yeah um
i like soda yeah but yes you just kind
of said it like that is true well he'll
go well we go to dollar general once a
month or once every few weeks or
something like that to stock up on
snacks once a week
and i'll just get i get like breakfasty
type stuff like i'll get some granola
bars or like peanut butter crackers
something like that that i can just like
eat like for a small breakfast or
whatever and you know coffee [ __ ] like
you know
you know creamer and stuff
and he'll go and get cookies and
lots and lots and lots of soda lots of
soda yeah i don't really i don't like
soda i like soda
the only quote unquote junk food drinks
i like i like those like starbucks
coffee drinks like in the bottle
actually i like any kind of like iced
coffee kind of drinks in a bottle the
dunkin donuts ones are good
ooh dunkin donuts
have a bottled coffee drink that well
they had a couple that were like based
on girl scout cookies
they had a thin mint one and i was like
super jazzed about that but then i got
it and it wasn't quite as good
i don't know i kind of feel like the
same thing happened with starbucks like
they had a mint chocolate one too and i
was like oh my god that's the best thing
because i love mint chocolate
but it wasn't i thought it would be
better you know what i mean i was just
kind of like man it was just kind of
blah
but the dunkin donuts one that's based
on samoas
with like a kind of a coconut flavor to
it is the bomb those are really really
really good
but um so those are good they actually
have
what did i say international delight who
makes the creamers yeah
they have canned coffee drinks they have
one that's caramel macchiato which is
okay that's not my really my favorite
flavor and they have one that's cookies
and cream like oreo which i thought
would be gross but is actually delicious
so those are really good
the starbucks ones
i like the plain coffee flavor
the mocha is good although i can only
drink like half the bottle the big
bottle at a time because it's kind of
rich
i'm not a fan of the caramel one and i'm
not a fan of the vanilla one sometimes
they have they have a salted caramel one
that's actually pretty good
some of the other flavors
are weird and i'm not into it but
they try to like put different ones out
but i really i don't like the vanilla
but you know i got a couple of mocha
ones but i drank half of it earlier and
i was just kind of like wait but i don't
like cream soda i don't like sodas
if i have to drink soda
i don't mind sprite
or 7up
root beer is good
ginger ale is good
i like dr pepper mr pibb
i don't like coke i don't like pepsi
i don't mind like orange soda like if
you have like fanta or something like
that that's pretty good but i can't
really drink a lot of it and it has to
be really really cold
you know what i mean yeah this is my
second favorite flock of video
okay y'all gonna like this one
this dude is [ __ ]
smoking
doing flocka i guess he's smoking flaka
and he's in his sister's shirt and he's
[ __ ] high as [ __ ] he's dancing
very unproductive
that's him
i told you
yeah the music to that well yeah
obviously but i'm just saying that if
you play that
it's gonna get demonetized
funny funnily enough whenever we go to
the bar and i get like really drunk and
i go out to dance that's what i feel
like i look like
i don't but that's kind of what i feel
like when i go out to dance with that
first song and i'm kind of like [ __ ]
her are these flocka peeps in florida
probably i don't know yeah flock is big
in florida in certain neighborhoods
are those ones in florida yeah pretty
much all probably pretty much all of one
floor and i'm not saying like i don't
know
yeah i don't know if you guys know but
the reason that florida man thing is a
meme
is because not not just because we have
all the crazy people down here although
that might be like a little bit of it
but it's because florida has something
called the sunshine law where if you get
arrested for whatever
um then it immediately becomes
public knowledge so if anybody is
writing like on the crime beat or
whatever
go ahead talk um if anybody's on the
crime beat or whatever
uh they can access all of the details of
your crime and your photo and all that
kind of stuff basically the public
humiliate yes well everything comes out
of florida they know yeah because some
states have a thing where it's like well
if you get until you get convicted of
the [ __ ] yeah um you know they can't
really do anything but florida is if you
get arrested for something then that's
it's public knowledge and everybody
knows about it so everybody knows that
so everybody likes searches florida for
crazy news stories yeah what's great
about this video to me is that he's
wearing wearing a girl's shirt it's a or
a girl's dress as a shirt
although if you hadn't said that i don't
really think i would have known yeah but
he is he's wearing some girl's shirt and
he's going to smoke some more flakka
and
because it doesn't really when you look
at him like that it just looks like a
regular t-shirt yeah he's trying to pass
it off as a regular shirt it does look
like a regular shirt it's not see how
it's real long and it's got tapered
waist and everything yeah it's a girl's
shirt like i said that the girls would
have occurred to me
if you hadn't said that yeah
and then it's talking to him and he's
just he and here's the deal he's not
friends filming this because that's kind
of like that's a douchey move well
they're in the hood when you're doing
all kind of like embarrassing [ __ ] and
they're like man we're gonna like post
this up publicly for everyone in the
world to like gawk at well they posted
music along with it like he's dancing
but the thing is is he is not dancing he
is trying to stand still
well yeah that's obviously he's trying
to stand still yeah but can you imagine
like i said
because you've seen those youtube videos
and like pictures and stuff like that of
you know spring break or st patrick's
day or whatever when like some college
girls went out and got like way more
[ __ ] up than usual and then like they
fell over in a gutter and like [ __ ]
themselves or something like that and
then like all of their friends well
friends because your real friends
wouldn't do that but then they're like
oh hilarious and then they film it and
then they put on youtube and then like
you super sober up the next day and now
everybody knows you as like hey the
chick that fell in the gutter and like
[ __ ] yourself yeah
so you know you're never gonna live that
down sorry thank you again zach
speaking of michael jackson
a show on gary indiana would be
hilarious because it's known only for
him being from there and the hellscape
it's become
yeah
yeah that actually might be an
interesting show i'm going to write that
down too we're we're writing down all
kind of ideas we've got
ideas it's cool the guy says he needs
some milk
[Laughter]
he needs some milk that's [ __ ] funny
jenny probably doesn't know what we're
talking about yeah i do because she told
me he needs some milk yeah
that [ __ ] is [ __ ] funny
too funky
they're talking about
you need some milk
i still haven't watched breaking bad or
better better calls all i really really
need to get into that i'm so behind yeah
you know what i mean yeah
um yeah um well i guess i'm gonna go to
the bathroom or just if you're just
gonna show videos the whole time
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
[ __ ] i ain't going over there
i bet that [ __ ] mojo they better
leave that [ __ ] alone
[Music]
he needs some milk
grandma
he needs some milk
cookie got bored what's that
yeah i guess what's that thing is that
supposed to be plugged in or whatever
yes yeah it's all right all right
all right
tom with the videos yeah yeah
jenny please watch breaking bad i will i
promise
i feel really bad that i've like left it
this long there's like so many shows
that i need to watch i feel like i'm so
behind on like the cultural [ __ ]
zeitgeist man
that was like years and years ago
yeah breaking bad is one of the yeah and
sopranos i still haven't seen the
sopranos either
like i said i kind of i know what
happens in the [ __ ] like i have a vague
just from osmosis like cultural osmosis
like i kind of know what happens in them
but i haven't like watched them
um so yellow jackets
a lot of people have been talking about
this is it good should i watch it
we'll see isn't stranger things season
four coming out soon i kind of feel like
didn't the trailer just come out
those kids look like they're like almost
adults at this point dude i wanted to
know if only black people were taking
flocka where are the white people taking
flocka no white people take flocka too
they're there just they don't have
famous videos yet or they don't have
maybe they don't have friends [ __ ]
enough to like film them
on youtube
no you just did you missed it because i
ran into a girl today at the biker bar
who she had all kinds of problems she
she was
paranoid schizophrenic and
and on something or off and on something
she was asking about
coke and asking about
meth and
but she was like that
and i was just babysitting her and then
she vanished
but uh
i got her a couple of beers but they
didn't charge them they didn't charge me
for them and i got to worry about it so
what they do like the bars eat the cost
or what yeah well i guess yeah they
didn't charge you for them they were tap
beers
okay and i just because they probably
figured i was just trying to keep her
it's calm you know
she asked for some drinks well like i
said you don't know what okay you don't
know what kind of people i mean other
than you you're fairly normal but like
what other kind of people are turning up
at a biker bar in the middle of the
afternoon yeah you know what i mean
right
so
some people might have some problems she
had some kind of problems
[Laughter]
sexual problems yeah sexual problems too
probably yeah well she
she she said she was a woman of the
trade in one of her little rants
and i was thinking hooker
but it never got to that she never came
back to that
it might have just been a delusion in
her mind at the time
all right she definitely
and then the bartender was like yeah my
daughter's got paranoids because a
friend she's off her medication that's
that's what the
so the bartender didn't charge me
for giving her some drinks
i kind of wonder sometimes yeah
like what
like where do they like where do they
live are they getting help i mean i hope
they are
she didn't answer any question i asked
her other than her what her name was
financially did she have a place to live
and like
i mean if she was had medication to be
off of then obviously someone's paying
for her medication so that's good but
every time i asked her a question she
answered with something that was
irrelevant to what i said the only
answer the only direct question she
answered was what what's your name she
said rebecca that was it
yeah interesting yeah so
and that and she said she hung out here
all the time
and she knew everybody here but nobody
nobody knew her nobody knew her nobody
never seen it we've run into some people
like that before
[Laughter]
we used to run into people like that at
eyebar yeah i'm here all the time i'm
here all the time like yeah we're here
all the time but we've never seen you
before so
you know and like we know all the
bartenders and they're like yeah we've
never seen that person before i don't
know who that is
um by the way i bar i found out where
they were moving to
where
uh john young parkway i don't know where
that is which
it's a little bit it's farther it's a
little bit farther it's on the other
side of downtown that's a wrap
if you ask me that's that's right i mean
i haven't seen the new location i don't
know but i just saw that john paul
posted that they were moving to a place
on genuine parkway so i will look at it
on google maps and we will see that
club's gone
but
that makes it really sad yeah i grew up
in that [ __ ] place location location
location and they lost that location
yeah it's just the end of that era
that blows yeah
i mean they were there for 30 something
years but still
all powers all the power and prestige
will go to mannequins
starting 78 says uh there's a character
in yellowjackets named natalie that i
can picture jenny being like in the 90s
oh now i really have to watch it and
we'll see we'll see if you're correct
that's what i was like in the 90s
campaign's talking about need milk no
that's not what that's not what he's
talking about that was got milk
that the commercial thing
need milk was some other like mimi thing
well
one of those drugs i don't know if it's
flaka but that black girl was talking
about she said that they are making it
now and she called it something else he
really starts freaking out but i didn't
get to the end of it she goes give him
some milk he needs some milk give him
some milk
and um
it sounded ridiculous but then it did
some more research and no that's she's
right you take the
take milk there's something some kind of
chemical in that milk the lactose i
think it's that [ __ ] lactic acid or
something breaks down the chemicals and
they they uh it kind of like uh acts
like a uh
an antidote to that drug
but what made it [ __ ] but what made
that give him some milk
famous in the meme world
is
there's a video that was
spliced together
of this white kid [ __ ]
putting his head down over a [ __ ]
fish tank at a big aquarium and there's
some sharks in the damn water
and he's having a staring match with the
sharks underneath the water and the
shark [ __ ]
its tail [ __ ] flies up and hits him
in the head and it's like it knocks him
out and he falls in the water and then
you hear the [ __ ] crowd people in the
crowd scream and you hear that same
black girl go give him some milk
but they lifted that voice out for that
one video that i just showed you and put
it into that one so it sounds even
though that makes absolutely no sense at
all
well when you see them [ __ ] floating
all [ __ ] well yeah i get it oh
[ __ ] hard
it's just i feel like there's i feel
like there's too many steps give us some
milk
for really good comedy to work
it has to be like pretty much like you
get the
if you have to go like a few steps to
get the connection then it's not funny
so it's like i get it but it's it's too
much of a reach that's too much of a
reach but what they cut out of that
video is that he [ __ ] immediately
comes to life and jumps out of the pool
that the whole thing was a setup god
damn it he didn't even buy sharks that
would have been yeah he was pretending
he pretended that the shark uh
you know if he got eaten by sharks that
would be funny he evidently worked at
the aquarium and
knew those sharks
and had done that with the sharks
several times just part of their
instincts if you're over them in the
water they'll splash their tail at you
to try to get you away he pretended that
it knocked him out that's pretty good
then somebody else
lift it in give him some milk like milk
will bring him back to life and it's
just [ __ ] funny you know
see i love this like oh well i've worked
here a long time i know these sharks
they won't bite my head off right until
they do
sharks don't give a [ __ ] about you yeah
you're just like a big walking like yeah
meat stick i might be able to find it
uh mike barrett says how often does tom
visit the bar lol
a couple times a week probably a couple
times a week yeah yeah
he goes on fridays and
usually sundays
like he kind of goes like for the
afternoon
uh part of meme culture is that they
often don't make sense i get that
um but that's the thing though a lot of
them do make sense that's why they're
funny you know what i mean
um even an old fart like me like i'll
see some of the memes i'm like oh i get
that that's funny but it's like that one
i get it
but
it's not i
that particular one isn't that funny
because there's too many steps you have
to go through to like [ __ ] it's just
it's too much of a reach that's what i'm
saying comedy should be it's pithy
you know get to it
um they used to have a guy that had
alligator wrestling at reptile museums
down there
they i think they still have that
i don't know how much of like alligator
wrestling they still do because that
seems a little
questionable nowadays
could be wrestling alligators
i just went to when i was in saint
augustine back in june
they still have they don't wrestle
alligators there obviously because it's
more of a
i got it
oh
that was the original that wasn't the
one where they played give him some meal
all right let me see
to give him some milk one's even [ __ ]
more funny
i don't know it's not there anymore
but you get the idea
he goes down and that [ __ ] hear that
that [ __ ] go give him some milk and the
timing was perfect it sounded like it
was she was in the crowd
the way they the way they had it
engine it had [ __ ] um spliced in
it was funny
john smith says at aquariums i've always
felt sorry for the other fish in the
tank with them the sharks swimming up
and down with your next grin i kind of
wonder about that too because you go to
larger aquariums and i know sharks you
know
get hungry and don't just eat everything
that's in front of them obviously
but
i do kind of feel like well
they have all these fish in the
aquariums and some of them are probably
pretty rare and [ __ ] like that
and
you never know like when nobody's
watching
it's like the middle of the night
little shark might be driving around
like driving around like swimming around
and he'd be like it'd be funny if a
shark was driving around and it was like
swimming around and he's just kind of
like i would i would like a midnight
time i'm gonna eat that nice rare
lionfish over there i'm just gonna
he's a little peckish and he's gonna get
him and the next morning they're like
where's that lionfish sharks like
i don't know i just kind of feel like
that might happen i know they feed them
a lot so that doesn't happen
but
they're wild animals i just can't really
see that not happening
but yeah so what i was going to say was
that i was at uh when i was in st
augustine i went to the alligator farm
and they don't do the alligator
wrestling thing because that's
dumb and it's like i don't really know
why you would do that but they're more
of a um you know they're trying to like
preserve alligators so they try to like
you know hatch their eggs and all that
kind of stuff so
but they do
uh do feeding shows like every day and i
videotaped it i don't remember if i
showed you guys on the show but
they have a thing like the guy that
comes out
and gives them the little they have
pellets they feed them
pretty much they feed them like chickens
and weasels and stuff like that they
bring them out in a wheelbarrow and like
throw them in there
but
when i went there last june i didn't
realize
how many alligators they had at the
alligator farm
until
they did that show and the guy he has
this little like platform that comes out
into the they have like a huge mangas
like lagoon that they all live in
and he has this little like platform
that he comes out on that's wood
and
even before he got out there
because all the tourists started
gathering around the path like outside
of the lagoon
so the alligators knew what was up they
knew what time it was they're not dumb
so they're like ooh feeding time so all
of them like start
and they all start like swimming around
there and there's like hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of them
and even before the guy like when he
first started walking up the thing they
were like
climbing like up on the [ __ ]
wooden deck and [ __ ] like that and
there's like someone were trying to like
jump on top of the other ones they're
like food's coming food's coming it was
just like oh my god it was crazy and
then like he starts throwing the [ __ ] in
the water and they're like jumping out
of the [ __ ] water and i was just like
jesus [ __ ] christ
i am never going [ __ ] in the water
it was like super super scary like
none of the alligators there like some
of the alligators there are pretty
big a lot of them are smaller but
a lot of them were like uh some of them
were like pretty [ __ ] big too so it
was like terrifying terrifying
um she does the stank face at me all the
time yeah i do yeah well
deservedly sound yeah
i don't worry about it i don't deserve
it i don't worry about it
well it's just because i don't worry
about it it's because you don't really
listen to anything i'm saying so it's
like i'll be talking and it'll be like
oh hey look at this thing and it's just
like he doesn't care you know he doesn't
care
here look at this video i found on
youtube that other people can easily
look for look for for themselves okay
white like don't show it no i'm just no
i'm i'm thinking about something else
right now
tammy says no female blames jenny for
giving tom that i know they don't i know
they don't
[Laughter]
yeah okay
what
i've been drinking all day
yeah no [ __ ] yeah
maybe it's like i haven't i've only had
this is only my second one
so you're like way ahead of me and
you're being like all cranky not being
crazy you were kind of like well you
were kind of like not cranky necessarily
but you were just kind of like
i'm slightly i'm sleepy i'm sleepy
so he goes to the bar and drinks all day
and then he comes back home and falls
asleep and then he gets mad when he has
to like be on the show i'm not me man
i'm not mad okay i'm not bad hey i've
been working all day but i've been
working since it's like seven in the
morning yeah you see how you guys got it
going i'm not mad don't be that way i'm
not see
[Laughter]
man camp guy says look up joe ball from
the 1920s he used to charge folks to see
him feed live animals to his alligators
he also supposedly disposed of some
bodies he killed as well oh okay i'm
gonna look that up
i do not i don't i don't know i don't
think i would like
i mean alligators got to eat i get that
um they got just as much right to be
here as anybody else they're scary but
like i said they've been here forever
and that's kind of like can you believe
that the wind's crazy
it's been well that's like not even bad
i don't even know if they heard that but
it's just like today
seriously i was just kind of like what
the [ __ ] is going on out there i don't
know if it's just because i'm like my
window is facing like a weird direction
it's like there's nothing like someone's
blocking it 60 mile an hour wind coming
around yeah it sounded like goddamn
tornado like all day today and like it
sounded like something was like knocking
into the window and i was like there's
nothing there that could possibly be
knocking into the window there's nothing
it's the driveway there's no trees
there's no nothing
so i don't really know what that [ __ ]
noise was it was like really really loud
now then they're talking about creating
a stink stank face emoji and [ __ ]
i know maybe i should do maybe i should
do like an emoji of my face going yeah
it's stay face
it's or something
it's all that estrogen it's all these
women is that what it is women in their
stank faces
well like i said we have reason for
doing that no it's not enough yeah we do
it's very dude-like to just be like well
you you're y'all are just crazy you
don't have any reason for it's not like
you guys are
it's not like you guys are doing
something like dickish
and we're just like reacting to that i
was just it couldn't be i was talking
about
the florida zombies and
[ __ ] flakka and how crazy these
[ __ ] are
and uh
i was providing video evidence
yeah right in the middle of me telling a
story about something else that's what
i'm saying how do you realize what's
more dangerous a gator or a croc
crocodiles or uh well crocodiles all
about the same crocodiles generally are
a lot more aggressive
but alligator can be dangerous
alligators are dangerous too and
honestly in florida
um alligators they're not aggressive
necessarily but
because we have so many alligators in
florida i feel like a lot of people do
stupid [ __ ] like feed them and so they
get used to being around people they're
not really afraid of people
um and that's
really not good either like i said we've
had a lot of cases where well there was
that famous one at the one of the disney
resorts
where the alligator came out and ate a
kid yeah essentially um
and they eat pets and [ __ ] like that all
the time so you really gotta [ __ ]
watch and honestly if there's a body of
water close enough to you
um
just assume that there's alligators in
there i think crocodiles probably there
are
i think crocodiles might be a little bit
more aggressive because where there are
crocodiles there tends to be more of
them in one spot and a lot more food so
i think they compete against each other
a lot
and um they fight a lot harder for food
that they see
alligators are kind of spread out
they're not as they're not
all competing against one another so i
think they're kind of chilled out
and i don't know about lifespans it
might be that alligators might live
longer i don't know but they just seem
slightly kind of
kind of toned back in their
in their behavior it's like they they
kind of feel like they have enough time
for everything
but they will come out of the water and
get you
the crazy thing about alligators and
they it's weird because they kind of go
into this if you go to the alligator
farm in san augustine there used to be a
alligator from miami too i don't know if
it's still there but the one in st
augustine is still there i went there in
june
now
they are very much like because a lot of
times
alligators
uh like a lot of reptiles they don't
have uh they're not warm-blooded
obviously so they their body temperature
is regulated by the outer temperature
so
they if they're cold or if it's kind of
cool out they have to like be still
until it's like warm enough for them to
like power up essentially
so a lot of times
when they're not eating or doing
something like that they're just kind of
like sitting there
so sometimes depending on what time of
day it is you go to the alligator farm
and you kind of walk through the lagoon
or whatever and a lot of the alligators
are just kind of like sitting there and
some of them are just like sitting with
their mouths open like just sitting like
that
and they look like
not real like they look concrete
so a lot of times there's like signs
saying yes they're real like please do
not climb into the [ __ ] [ __ ] it's
like yes they look like they're made of
concrete and stuff but if you dangle
some food in front of their face you
will see
how fast they can [ __ ] move that's
why i think they started doing the
feeding shows because i think they used
to only do them once a week now they do
them every day
because they want to show people
when they know that it's feeding time
alligators will absolutely move very
very quickly and they can jump out of
the water and
you
you would be really hosed if you're like
right by the [ __ ] [ __ ] because i kind
of feel like some people are like think
it'd be funny it's like look they're not
even moving they're just all sitting
there and they're gonna like jump over
the fence and stuff and they're like
yeah you're probably gonna regret that
decision because they can move really
really fast when they want to
yeah you can't really chew they just
kind of grab you
and they'll just uh
if you're fighting them they'll roll
and if there's more alligators they're
fighting over the same animal they'll
start to roll and they'll you'll get all
busted up
because
one alligators gotcha he's trying to
roll and another animals another
alligator will grab some pieces sticking
out of that mouth and he's not gonna
roll and they're gonna tear you into
pieces
but yeah you're just like meat to that
you're like a pork roast but if you're
not really fighting back or giving them
much of a fight they just go down the
bottom and sit down on the bottom you
drowned
they don't even yeah they'll save you
for later yeah they don't even bite hard
i mean they can hold you but they're not
they're not trying to bite you in half
they're just holding you
and they'll drown you yeah they're just
trying to get you to stop squirming yeah
that that's that's
is all they're trying to do right then
they'll just tuck you under there
they're like i'm gonna eat that later
yeah
it's happens to those kids it's not like
it
bites them to death or anything just
grabs them and swims down the bottom the
kids drowned kids drowns
i mean they're i mean the way that the
the bite force that they have will
absolutely take your hand or your arm
off yeah uh depending on the size
because that has happened like they've
had trainers like had their arms or
hands bit off
um but normally if the gator wants to
eat you
it's just grabbing you so it can drag
you into the water and it rolls
right and you know so it can like put
and but then it'll like take you down to
like drown you so you'll stop wiggling
yeah and then it'll like save you for
late and it'll just like pick parts i
think that's how they lose their hands
and their arms though yeah they bite the
hand of the arm and then then you start
fighting and the alligator rolls and it
rips and rips your head off rips your
hand off well that happened with um i
think there was kind of like several
years ago there was a very famous photo
that went around and a lot of people
thought that it was doctored it was
photoshopped um and it had it was a
picture of an alligator and it had like
a dude's hand like sticking out of the
jaw
and snopes looked into it a bunch of
people looked into it and they said no
this is absolutely real uh that was the
thing that happened it was a trainer i
don't think it was in the u.s i think it
might have been in asia somewhere um but
yeah the per he leaned too close like
doing something with the alligator and
the alligator just like snapped and like
popped his [ __ ] hand off and just
there was a picture of him like i don't
know who took the picture but the
pictures there was just like a perfectly
nice like man's hand like laying out
like hanging out his mouth like that but
you know it's gets pretty [ __ ] up but
uh i was gonna say something else but i
forgot what it was crocs are bigger as
well they tend to be yeah
um at the alligator front and honestly
as far as i know
as far as i know florida everglades in
the southern power floor the big swamp
is the only place on earth as far as i'm
aware uh where alligators and crocodiles
live in the same habitat i think that's
the only place if you go to the
alligator farm they have crocodiles
there as well uh they have a big
crocodile display of like crocodiles
from all over the world they have like
some of those ones that have those big
long
needle noses and they have like all that
kind of stuff they also have some like
albino alligators they have all that
kind of stuff it's really cool
um
camp guy said i had a friend that had a
python that was wrapping around him they
had to kill the snake to get it off the
dude
i've
that's the thing i've had
friends that had pythons and most of
them were pretty chill
but i have heard of a few cases where
yeah where uh the python got out and
like got got the dog or got the baby or
something you know what i mean
so it does happen i i don't think it's
that common but it does happen i
actually i quite like pythons they they
seem like pretty cool but you know i
don't know if i would have one as a pet
not with other animals around because
python would look at pookie and be like
look at that little
nugget you know what i mean and that
would be
really [ __ ] up
i used to be really paranoid at our old
house because
pookie would go out and run around in
the backyard and sometimes even though
we told her not to
uh she would go kind of like under the
fence or she would kind of go down to
the water hole or something like that
and i was kind of worried that like
someone was gonna get her nothing did
thankfully but
and now that we've moved to this new
house she is absolutely seems completely
uninterested in going outside
she jumps up on the
you know the windowsill
and looks out the window
but
i think it might be completely because
the next door has two dogs
that are always in the backyard because
she's always kind of like jumping up
looking over there like looking at the
dogs
because that dog scared her that one
time and i think she hasn't forgotten
about it so she doesn't really like to
go so she'll go like down to the to the
sliding glass window like in the living
room and she'll kind of look out and be
like i kind of want to go outside like
on the back porch but then she kind of
goes out for a second and then she'll be
like no [ __ ] and then she'll come
back in
but that's okay with me she can stay
inside she doesn't really go downstairs
that much she mostly stays up here
upstairs is kind of like her little
kingdom now
she just tries to keep pookie from
coming up here keep beijing from beijing
for coming up here yeah yeah we've
talked about that before she's
she has a thing where it's like at night
like when we're kind of like getting
ready to like watch movies or whatever
for the night she goes out in the hall
and like she lays
like this with her little paws crossed
like at the top of the staircase and
just watches
just making sure like beijing just come
up there
beijing doesn't really try to come up
here all that much
sometimes she does but i haven't seen
her up here
beijing hasn't come up here in like
[ __ ]
probably a couple of weeks at this point
i haven't seen her up here in a couple
of weeks
he said they'd never tasted alligator
before gator is kind of flaky a little
bit dry it's okay it's kind of fishy
slightly fishy flavored
i um it being like more mild than fish
like not as fishy as fish but still kind
of fishy it's kind of not as good as
saint turtle turtle is better
but similar to turtle
kind of like
kind of like a snake
if your red snake it's a little bit like
that
but the flakes
the flakes of the meat are bigger
it's a little drier
it's it's hard to cook most people will
cook it on a barbecue grill
and um
it has a slight fishy flavor to it
it's it's just okay it's it's not
something that i would
pay a lot of money for
you know
although they got people that will but i
wouldn't
yeah it's good but it's not like
anything special yeah no
i mean you can get
you can get other seafood or anything
something else like that that tastes
pretty much the same or better or better
so lobster is a lot better
yeah that's what i mean
tuna is better if you ask me yeah to be
honest yeah
but like it all kind of tasted and i
love and i love seafood but to me it's
like i've had alligator once or twice
and i was just kind of like that's good
but it wasn't anything like mind blowing
no you know what i mean it just seemed
like kind of like oh okay more of that
right that's all
tila says i just finished that rick
james book
confessions of a super freak jenny you
all should do a show
on infamous celebrities because rick was
a real super freak we should actually
probably do a show on rick james let's
write that down let's write that down
i wonder how much of it was true
did you talk about the girl that they
that they kept and who who said that
she she uh she said that they burned her
with a car cigarette lighter and kept
her as a sex slave type of deal
it didn't really sound 100 legit to me
but it did go to court but i think it
got but weirder things have happened
yeah weird things have happened it was
rick james and his girlfriend captured
some other girl or she claimed that they
captured but it might have just been
crack cocaine you know
crackheads will [ __ ] come up with all
kinds of crazy stories
but that's all kind of crackheads well
that's the thing too is that
yeah crack will make you come up with a
bunch of stories but it'll always also
make you do a bunch of crazy [ __ ] so
they might have done some of that [ __ ]
too yeah but she would have been like
there's no way i've known she would have
been crackhead and they're doing it to
her
but she's well that doesn't excuse it no
but she's staying because of the crack
you know what i mean so yeah
and they're all they're all they're all
of diminished capacity you know yeah i
guess that's a nice way of putting it
it's not normal people
i could leave but i'm going to stay
because of the crack because the crack
is the crack yeah
that's sweet sweet crack yeah
never done crack
it can't be that awesome she says um
yeah he talks about tommy's real
transparent in the book
about it okay that sounds good actually
yeah
uh i feel like zoe lund from miss 45
would be a great subject too that's
actually a really good idea i was always
kind of like fascinated with her
actually
um i'm gonna wrap her down too
she died like quite young actually
rick james died pretty young
well
you live like that like i said we've
talked about this before you kind of
live like that you either like live
forever
or you die like really really young uh
he i think he didn't make it to his 50s
so you might have been late 40s very
early 50s when he died
that's just based on my memory he didn't
live very long
i also think he died broke i think you
know if i remember that's pretty broke
you know what you want to hear something
hilarious
i remember very distinctly being in
sixth grade
so i was 12 years old so
what was it 1984 1984
and i remember thinking to myself
in the year 2000 which seemed like a
very long way away when i was from you
know from 1984 i will be 38
what was it 38 years old or 28 years old
i can't remember i can't math
and i was like god i'll be so old
isn't that funny and now like 2 000 is
like [ __ ] 22 years ago yeah
it's just like funny that i still
remember thinking that like when i was
12 years old like thinking how how old
would you be like how old i would be in
2000 i'm like oh my god i'll be so old
that's crazy
2 000. and now it's like [ __ ] 2022.
yeah we're like in the [ __ ] future i
thought there'd be like jets and [ __ ]
going on flying cars
i feel ripped off yeah
[Laughter]
not really what did what did the jetsons
have that was like cooler than what we
have now
i don't know robot
yeah i guess like grow up but well we
kind of have [ __ ] like well not quite
but we kind of have some [ __ ] like that
their house didn't their houses didn't
have any walls remember that was just
glass
yeah i don't like that
okay now one thing one thing that they
did have that i thought was rad
was that
i love that
the jetsons even though it was supposed
to be the future still had like the
standard like dude goes to work like
woman stays home and takes care of the
house kind of thing it was it was 50s
yeah that's what i mean it was like 50s
projected into the like future which i
thought was like very funny
but one thing that she had that i was
like really into was like she had a
thing where she could just like sit in
front of a mirror and like basically
like spray like a pretty face onto her
face and i was just kind of like okay i
want that
i want that like which it would just
like she bring like perfect makeup and
perfect hair on didn't she put her face
in a cone and then when she pulled it
back it had makeup on her
no i thought it was just like a spray
thing if i remember the i'm trying to
think of like the because it was in the
credits like the opening credits like it
showed like oh all the crazy [ __ ] the
jetsons had and i think she just like
sat in front of a mirror and it was just
like
and it's just like like beautiful makeup
and face and beautiful perfect hair and
i was just kind of like
yeah i would like that it's been so long
i don't remember so i don't have to like
[ __ ] actually do that [ __ ] that would
be awesome they had video phones but
they didn't have internet
yeah that's what i mean that's what's
like so funny about it yeah
well no one could have imagined the
internet really back then some people
did imagine the internet but that was
like part of the [ __ ] darpa and uh
military industrial complex were coming
up with what you could do with an
internet
and a lot of it had to do with
communication between the military bases
and nuclear warfare and stuff
and then you could take you could take
this internet and hook it up to us to a
central processing unit or a computer
and get it to manage your nuclear attack
strategies and stuff that's where they
came up with that [ __ ] [ __ ] on uh
terminator with uh skynet
skynet is the internet it's what they're
talking about
the internet between all your missiles
i have to say that
the novel enders game by orson scott
card
i can't remember what year it was
written but it was like pretty early
when i remember reading that
in the 80s
and then later realizing man
what he was talking about in that was
essentially the internet like people
were uploading
like information to it and everybody
could access it
it was very much like the internet i
remember thinking that so it was like it
was pretty early like so some people
like knew what was going on
well this new thing that uh
oh robot head is trying to make but
zuckerberg
talking about the metaverse
that is what i was trying to describe
when i was talking about
extraterrestrials
i was talking about like the big
those big ships or things that seem like
ships like on the uh
you know the [ __ ] the phoenix lights
accounts where yeah the thing is sucking
a mile wingtip to wingtip
i think it's more kind of like not
really a ship as you would know it a
ship as we know it
flies around it's hollow it's got people
in it and rooms and you know
food and
oxygen and
you live in it you know it takes care of
your biology that's i don't i don't
think that's what it is
i think it's just
all machine
and
there are people living in it or aliens
in it but they're machine intelligences
and they're they're downloaded into it
like an internet and then and they are
in there living in a metaverse
you know
yeah they might be able to look out to
see where they are from time to time but
most of the time
they're in they're in there in their
metaverse you know
fantasizing that they're at the casino
or
interacting with one another and
they're immortal in a heaven-like state
yeah black mirror didn't it like that
yeah that's that's what it is
and the chances are aliens would be like
that there's no reason why they would be
biological
they're just i mean if you can abandon
like biological [ __ ] it's like i yeah i
can see i would do that
because that's the ultimate it's just a
nuisance the nuisance especially the
body is a nuisance especially in space
you know because you
if you have a spaceship that's carrying
around atmosphere and has to grow and
produce food
uh the the occupants don't live very
long so you need re
reproduction and education to make new
replacements you know new replacement
uh generations that's a that's very
taxing
on a ship it's a lot more efficient
if their souls are all out of a damn
body and put into a damn
machine and they're in a metaverse like
a heaven-like
metaverse where they can they're real
they're not
they're not
you know uh
imitation people they are real people
in kind of like soul form
in a
internet slash metaverse type
situation in that
craft
which would be kind of like what you see
from 2001 and and the in the monolith
the monolith might be that
it's not one thing it's an entire
species
of machine intelligences inside there in
the mountain in a
in a uh metaverse or maybe they're not
inside there there's many of those
monoliths
and they're kind of like uh and they're
a network of monoliths that they kind of
can communicate with
you know
from their metaverse
and whenever a monolith gets somewhere
they can kind of just click over and
scroll over to that change the window
and they can experience reality wherever
that monolith is you know
something like that like an ultimate
sensory apparatus
it's going to be something that like
that
so
i was imagining it but i didn't have a
word for it i think that's what i think
is in those so-called alien spaceships
they're more like met their machine
intelligence is in inside of a metaverse
i think that's probably what it is
and i mean totally somebody needs to get
on that because if i could pop my
[ __ ] consciousness into a
robot avatar or
well it's an avatar online like i would
totally do that it's an avatar inside
the metaverse that's okay all right
and it all feels real to you that's what
i mean i'm down there
i would do it but i would only do it
once i was old and again and death was
imminent anyway or you're terminally ill
you know i said well now it's time to go
you know well i don't want to wait that
long because by the time i get to that
point like my brain might be [ __ ]
deteriorated there's always a chance
though that you get in there and you die
i mean i'm gonna i'm gonna get in there
when i'm still like [ __ ]
spry enough to like know what's going on
like well maybe you don't though maybe
you go in there and you're dead
yeah but i wouldn't know any different
would i
well if you kill yourself and you
wouldn't know any better that's not well
exactly that's what i'm saying i would
go i would go i would go um at the last
minute pretty much be like yeah this
life's over i'm gonna go ahead go in
there and see what that's like if it may
kill me i don't know it's just like the
star trek transporter it transports you
but it disassembles you and reassembles
you
are you a copy
or are you are you dead and is that a
copy of you running around thinking
that's you or or is that really you yeah
so there's so many like kirks and spocks
and balloons like running around the
universe you don't know
because they keep making copies it might
be a copy it may not be
you might have died when that happened
i don't know why i just remember that
stupid snl sketch but um was that an snl
sketch making copies
yeah i think it was
but um
yeah what was i going to say i was going
to say something about
[ __ ] something you just said and then i
just like forgot all about it tila is
like i wonder who the longest living
popular music artist is is a paul
mccartney that's what they've been
talking about for the last few minutes
uh the longest living popular musicals
like one that's still alive
yeah paul mccartney's still alive um
mick jagger's still alive
uh cher is still alive 75.
keith richards is 78
uh tom jones and shirley it's wait is
shirley bassey still alive i didn't
realize that i didn't think tom jones
was still alive either but it's like you
know i don't know tina turner uh she's
alive
little richard is still alive no way is
he really
dude's alive holy crap
holy crap
shirley bassey is 85. holy [ __ ] i don't
realize some of these people are still
around
connor watson says i've always wondered
why if our planet is three-quarters
water there are no aquatic humans maybe
there are
maybe that mermaid documentary was real
well you would think an aquatic human
would be a whale
yeah i mean i kind of feel like whales
in a lot of ways are that'd be about
that they're probably like smarter than
some humans i know so it's difficult to
say
they seem smarter
they don't
they've talked about that before
in in a in an aquatic type world
there's no chance of any kind of
technology so
you're not going to have you're not
going to have a human type intelligence
there because you can't make fire
if you can't make fire then you can't
make any advanced tools
if you're intelligent enough to make
advanced tools you're slowly probably
going to gravitate out out to the water
you know to become a land animal over
over time
probably how that would go
and then you see some animals
that are aquatic that do have real good
intelligence
like
octopi
and things like
humboldt squid
but the problem with them is that they
don't live very long they don't live
long enough as soon as a male octopus
mates he dies
just it's weird
they're just not built to last
well even i think some uh some species
of octopi
as soon as the female has
shepherded the next generation
like she's she watches over the eggs but
then after the eggs hatch she dies too
i think they only live like two years
yeah it depends on the species so
there's a lot of different species and
the hum bolts are constantly uh they're
supposed to be pretty intelligent
but they're uh
super hungry because they grow so
quickly and they'll uh go into feeding
frenzies and eat each other
you know they'll eat anything i'm just
so hungry dave i'm sorry yeah
yeah but they're
you're an [ __ ] i thought you were my
friend it's kind of a weird situation
where they're
partly primitive and part advanced you
know they can change colors and do all
these weird patterns which has something
to do with
something to do with communication they
seem to understand what
what's being shown to them
in those patterns
but you know but i don't know how how
they figure anything out they're not
around very long
so just almost be genetic yeah a lot of
it must be like encoded and coated into
them
but then they
they can solve all kinds of problems you
know unscrew lids and take lids off of
things and go in and
they do things kind of on par with what
a monkey can do pretty good intel pretty
good memory but like i said they don't
live long so i mean maybe it's a good
thing they don't because if they lived
longer they'd probably like take over
the [ __ ]
they seem to be built just to reproduce
and die
because that's what they do well like i
said but the interesting thing is that
they seem to be a lot more intelligent
than they really need to be
you know
which is which is kind of something
about the way they're built the same
thing with birds birds are a lot more
intelligent than they would actually
need to be but they can
do something yeah particularly like
corvids like crows and ravens and stuff
like that are like frighteningly
intelligent yeah and uh
i mean there's no like
necessarily like reason for them to be
that smart because other birds aren't
that smart like particularly like birds
of prey like owls and stuff like that
aren't they're not dumb but they're not
as smart
and a parrot can live over 100 years old
and still be in pretty good shape they
can remember a bunch of stuff and they
remember the people that raised them and
you know have friends and
you know have friends with friendships
with cats and things with cats there's a
lot of good videos of them
playing with cats and playing jokes on
cats and
you know
pretty intelligent
for what they are
you know they don't have to be that
intelligent
but they are you know what i think it
might be i think that
animals that and this you probably
doesn't apply across the board good but
i kind of got the impression that
animals that are more like like we said
like generalists
um in terms of like what they eat or
what their lifestyle is like tend to be
more intelligent because they have to
figure stuff out
if you are
you know if you're say like a predator
in the wild and all you have to do is
like well all i have to do is like stalk
and kill this one although predators do
kind of seem to be like a little bit
smarter because a lot of times they do
have to like like wolves for example
have to like work together with other
wolves so they have to like have some
kind of communication thing going on so
they can
you know have like patterns and like uh
catch their prey or whatever
so
i do kind of feel like
species that are generalists though
tend to be more intelligent
because i guess their thinking has to be
more flexible
in a way maybe that's what it is
but i don't think that applies across
the board though
well they're talking about you know the
occupy and stuff you know the occupy
evidently the brains are out throughout
the entire body
like there's there's neurons and brain
cells that go down on the legs and
everything so
it's hard to know
how intelligent or how big their brain
really is
because it's kind of disseminated
throughout the whole body
it's all the brain
which is strange for people to think
about because our brains are kind of
like confined in our heads and stuff but
the thing about
thinking cells or seeing cells or
anything like that they're just cells
um they can be anywhere on a body yeah
and i think that's like a weird concept
to us i was watching um if you guys
[ __ ]
uh if you guys are into like z frank the
guy that does true facts about animals
and he's like really funny
he only puts out a video like once every
couple of months but they're always
totally worth it
he put one up earlier today about
like starfish and brittle stars and that
kind of stuff
and
that whole
class of like animals is just so
fascinating because
basically
the thing that starfish and brittle
stars and those kind of things have is
that you know how humans
have stem cells if you have stem stem
cells just means that if you don't know
it means that
you know before you become like a human
really like all the cells you have can
kind of like be whatever they're just
like generalist cells and it's like well
this one's going to end up in the brain
or this one's going to end up in the
eyeballs and it's going to do that
but once it's kind of like fixed into
the position that it's going to be
it stays like that
but
the uh starfish and stuff like that they
have the same thing like the stem cells
but
their cells stay flexible like
throughout their entire lives so for
example if
some predator comes along and eats off
one of their arms
then they have stem cells that'll be
like oh well now we're in arm and they
can use their
regular ass cells and they can build
another arm or if they just have an arm
left they can build another start fish
on the end of that which is [ __ ]
crazy and honestly like i was watching
this video
and i was thinking to myself man
these are weird-ass [ __ ] animals like
i had seen them before but like some of
the
i don't know like some of the video they
had of them was like super super weird
and i was just kind of like you never
think about
i guess because i grew up by the beach
and like starfish you just kind of saw
them and they just kind of like sat
there
and
i think when i was a kid i didn't
realize that they were actually like
alive and they could like walk and stuff
they're slow
but
they're still animals and they can walk
they have like little bitty
little cilia or like little legs or
something like that on the bottom and
they can like actually kind of like move
around like i said they're slow but it
does happen
so
it was kind of like mind-blowing to like
see this kind of stuff and i'm just like
man [ __ ] earth is so crazy and like
people talk about aliens and stuff like
that i'm like we got [ __ ] weird-ass
[ __ ] animals like right here on
[ __ ] earth
you know you have to look for aliens we
got weird [ __ ] look at some [ __ ]
weird ass starfish they do some weird
ass [ __ ]
i mean they can grow back like whole
[ __ ]
arms and everything like that because
like i said their
their cells never
lock into a certain thing which we have
that too but
once you're born and the cells all kind
of like go into their places
then they can't be changed
um which actually if starfish can do
that and if we kind of have the same
thing
that makes me wonder if at some point in
the future we might not be able to like
take our own stem cells
later and be like can we keep these
activated like when we get older and
it's like hey
you know hey my arm got ripped off i'm
gonna just go
i'm gonna grow another one you know what
i mean the starfish can do it
and they have the same cells that you
know we're distantly related to them
they have the same cell cells as us it's
just the only difference is
no
she's just gonna do it the only
difference is their stem cells don't
once they're born it doesn't become
locked into one thing you know what i
mean their stem cells stay flexible
so i wonder if
at some point in the future like we
could have that done too
and so you could just like grow [ __ ]
third arms you could do whatever the
[ __ ] you wanted that'd be super fun
that'd be really fun
hey
she's crazy
she's gonna tear this [ __ ] apart huh
then she looks at me goes yeah
yeah what are you gonna do yeah i'm
gonna tear it apart
yeah what's wrong with that yeah
she just does well she just does that
when she wants attention yeah pretty
much like if she if you do something
that makes her mad or if you're not
paying enough attention to her
yeah then she goes up there and
scratches on it because she knows you're
going to turn around and be like hey
look it up yeah
jeffy heart says i used to feed the
crows at my college when i was getting
my mfa after a while they would watch me
when i walked to or from my car
kind of eerie but cool yeah crows
i've read a bunch of books about crows
and ravens and stuff like that like
people that keep them and people that
study them
um
crows and ravens are actually
frighteningly smart
they can figure out stuff
that even some apes can't figure out
and
which is kind of crazy because you would
think that in their
evolutionary niche if you want to call
it that that they wouldn't need to be
that smart but they absolutely are they
remember people's faces they can figure
out puzzles they can figure out all kind
of stuff that like i said even some apes
can't figure out which
you know i don't know why but they fly
around they're scavengers
so this is like i said generalists
they're generalists so they're there's a
they see a lot of [ __ ] on on a daily
basis so they're trying they have to
have game that's what that's really what
it boils down to well that's kind of
what i was getting at that's kind of
what i was getting at that's what i was
saying why that's why i think that
species that are more generalist yeah
like humans are like certain kind of
birds are
um
they tend to be more
intelligent i guess but then i don't
know it but in some ways it seems kind
of random because it's like so it's
humans
um whose intelligence is debatable
overall you got uh crows and ravens you
got
dolphins and whales
who are also frighteningly intelligent
they get like octopus and stuff like
that
and
i can't really think of anything that
like links all of those species together
necessarily that would make them have to
be as intelligent as they are yeah
the crows were flying around
the dumb ones all got killed
which yeah but you would think that that
was true of every species though well
just something having to do with the
situation out there the dumb ones didn't
make it and what got selected were the
ones that
had skill that'd be a way to put it
because they're just kind of skillful
they're trying to figure [ __ ] out
they're cheating basically they're not
playing by the rules they're cheating
like oh if i open this and then i can
get it
yeah if i do this or that then i can get
it if i can trick this animal i'll get
that food
that's that's what they're doing
well they've even figured out like how
to like
adapt to the modern world in the sense
that well here's this nut or this acorn
or something like that i'm gonna throw
it in the road and let a car run over
and break it and i get it and then i
don't have to break it myself
and you know not only do they remember
faces but i was reading i have this
really good book called the mind of the
raven
which is an ornithologist and he keeps
ravens and he was like writing about
studies he'd done with them
and one thing that he noticed was that
crows and ravens and stuff like that
um you get them little pieces of meat
and
they will save them you know for they'll
eat some of them now but they'll they'll
save some of her later and it's like
they'll bury them
and they bury them kind of like all over
and they'll leave them for like a long
time pieces of meat yeah like little
pieces well they'll bear them like kind
of deep or whatever i don't care if they
i don't know if they care if it rots or
not but they absolutely remember where
every single one of those pieces of meat
is buried and he's like and they bury a
lot of them like in a bunch of different
places because they're trying to like
not have other birds steal them
so they kind of go and they have all
these little places and they're trying
to like look and make sure hey i gotta
make sure carl's not watching me or
whatever i gotta i'm by myself and i'm
burying the [ __ ] and then they
absolutely remember everything but i'm
like well they're smarter than me then
because [ __ ] man i put stuff down all
the time and don't remember where it is
so
they're a lot smarter than i am
how long we've been going
not that long only two hours two hours
that's lonely it's not long that's long
[Laughter]
time's in a bad mood today no
no no just
sleepy
how can you be sleepy
i don't know you slept too late today
just tired
mr 88 says something like 98 of the
ocean is completely unexplored who knows
what exists there see that's kind of
[ __ ] that scares me
ocean life that exists below the light
line in the ocean has just been
discovered in the last 20 years or so
yeah it's
honestly we know more about [ __ ]
space
than we do about the bottom of the ocean
because we just can't get down there
it's like we've only really been going
down there in unmanned kind of like [ __ ]
for
you know the last couple decades
something like that before that it was
just
we had no [ __ ] idea what was going on
down there so well they kind of image to
the bottom of it
yeah the lights but they kind of know
what it looks like you can't really go
down there and like swim around and like
see what's down there though they drop
cameras
in those areas it's mostly like a desert
on the bottom it's just a real high
pressure
there's nothing really there
there's no food down there
not in not in great quantities so there
isn't a whole lot of life there there is
in certain areas like around thermal
vents and
but which for a long time they thought
that there wouldn't be any life around
that because it would be too hot there'd
be too many like toxic chemicals or
whatever but yeah yeah there's a lot of
and i think that that
that finding in particular
i think that kind of kicked off a lot of
people that are like exobiologists and
stuff like that that were really
interested in
um you know talking about life on other
planets or whatever and they were just
kind of like look even on earth
we have these animals that are living
by the in these conditions that
previously we thought were like
not like completely not conducive to
life and they found life there too
so
obviously that was like opening up the
window of
you know the conditions that would
support life even though it was like you
know what they call what they call them
extremophiles right yeah
in the real deep ocean the most the most
common things that were microbes those
are just looking everywhere
well yeah growth don't even know
they don't know anything about being
deep
it's all normal for them
well they wouldn't know any different
they're just like hey i'm born here and
it's like whatever this is like a cool
place there'll be things like little
sharing their microbe stuff a little
wispy looking little shrimp will walk by
on the bottom
but there isn't a whole lot of food
and it's cold
so i think that's a problem if you were
to drop something off say like drop a
damn whale into the water
it doesn't even make it down to the
bottom it'll just get to a certain level
it'll just hang there and things will
eat it
you think that things would fall all the
way to the bottom but it doesn't
pieces of metal and stuff will
but
if you were to drop a whale off a dead
whale it wouldn't even fall it wouldn't
even go it wouldn't even go down the
bottom
it would just get to a certain area
where
it would just kind of become buoyant if
i remember correctly
i mean
whales whales have always been like
really fascinating to me not only
because they're [ __ ] gigantic yeah
but also because
as i said they seem to be like a lot
more into they seem to have not only
intelligence but they seem to have
culture
yeah in the sense that ones that live in
different areas of the world
have their own
for lack of a better word languages yeah
you go to because you have like
scientists that study this stuff and
they're just kind of like look we
recorded whale song in this part of the
world and then we go to this other place
and that's the same species but we
recorded their whale song and it's like
kind of different like a different
dialect well whale um elephants too yeah
elephant like still that's another
animal that's like super super
intelligent and probably more
intelligent than it needs to be given
its uh ecological niche
but
yeah that's [ __ ] crazy which which
like i said makes me even like matter
that they put like elephants in circuses
and stuff you can see why they go
batshit every now and then and stomp
everybody to death
just saying
yeah well they're trying to get that off
and do something that it's not built
that's what i'm saying um
so i kind of like feel like it's
probably better to not put them into
circles no cigarettes just [ __ ] suck
they do yeah they do honestly i'm not a
big fan of zoos either
unless
um
it's not really a zoo but like more of a
sanctuary type situation
because i've been to some zoos when i
was a kid
i remember i don't remember where it was
but i remember going to one zoo when i
was a kid
and the animals all seemed like they
were in these really even like the big
cats and stuff like that they were in
these like little bitty
enclosures
and little bitty and even as a kid i was
just kind of like
i really don't feel like this animal
should be like living in this tiny
little i mean normally they would live
in like this big
expansive area and like you're confining
them these little they must be [ __ ]
going crazy in there a human absolutely
would so i don't see why an animal
wouldn't
um so i do kind of like the more
uh if you're gonna have a zoo if you're
gonna have something like that like i'm
not a huge fan of disney but their
animal kingdom is actually more like
if you're gonna have a zoo that's more
like what it would be like because they
don't have cages they don't have
anything like that it's just like a big
open park yeah it's it's a big open area
the animals can like run around
and
you know people can come and look at
them and stuff but it's like they have a
lot of room to run around and they take
they're taken care of and [ __ ] like that
so that's fine well it goes back to all
that tiger king [ __ ]
because
there's all there's these wild and we
have these wild animal species and
there's no habitat for them it's a lot
of it's gone
you do have animals walking around in
[ __ ] parks in africa
but
that those pieces of land can only
support so many animals
there are more of them in captivity than
there are in the wild
if you if you get rid of things like
zoos
i can understand getting rid of [ __ ]
uh circuses i think circuses are [ __ ]
that's retro [ __ ] anyway it is yeah
who goes to circus
um but you start getting rid of them in
zoos then that means you're wiping out
[ __ ] probably most of the elephant
population most of them are in captivity
you gotta have to the same thing with
those lions you got the the lion king
he just had that was around here in
florida he just had that um lion and
tiger
zoo basically and they were just
giving birth to more and more cats in
there
and he had all these cats
getting free cats
coming out of nowhere well those cats
would have never existed if it wasn't
for him they're being born in captivity
you can't really release them you can't
release them in florida they get killed
or they kill people
you can't take them back to where they
come from because there's too many cats
wild
there
you know the land can only support so
many of them
so there's got to be some kind of happy
medium where mankind
lives in harmony with animals in
captivity
and believe it or not eastern europe and
in russia and stuff where they allow
people to have the big cats like servals
and and and mountain lions and
panthers and
big cats right well
this guy's on there you know [ __ ] i
am pumas one of the channels
and he's just got some cats out in the
back and it's it's done to spec you know
like a habitats
but he lets that mountain lion just live
in the house with him like it's pookie
and i wouldn't think it'd be possible
but that cat loves that man
just you know
gets in bed with him hugs him i mean one
day it might need his face off but maybe
not maybe not he thinks he might not
calls you know basically you know his
wife is like oh there's daddy there's
daddy he's just looking he sees daddy
coming
outside walking up to the front door and
just freaking out oh daddy's home you
know now that that cat loves that man
but he's raised that cat
so
depending on how things go here on the
planet
that may be the future of those species
is to evolve alongside man
maybe for hundreds of thousands or
millions of years
to where there are no
wild
lions and tigers that they're now a
domestic
house cat
you know that's very possible
because the the domestic cat was wild
the horse used to be wild well the
interesting thing about domestic cats
is that
they're kind of one of those few species
that actually sort of domesticated
themselves yeah just hanging out in the
sense that
other animals like dogs um you know
started out as wolves and
you know the wolves that kind of hung
out by the human camps
got more and more
uh you know conducive to human behavior
and like friendly toward humans so that
was
uh you know that was encouraged so
you know the the breeding like bore that
out
i kind of feel like cats were more kind
of like well we're kind of like approach
you
and
we kind of want some food but we're not
like gonna be like nice to you or
anything we're just gonna like hang back
for a second
but so i kind of feel like domestic cats
are not as domesticated as dogs are i
will say that in the sense that
um people that have you know pet dogs
dogs are
people pleasers
they are very they're pack animals
so they see their
master
as they they kind of look up that we
want to do everything we want to please
that master yeah cats don't have that
which is why i always like cats more
than dogs but cats are very kind of like
yeah like you're they're not really pack
animals really they're not that's what i
mean they're not pack animals so it's
like i'm gonna hang out with you because
you feed me and you're nice to me yeah
but like you don't own me [ __ ] i know i
kind of like that better i like that
another possibility is that
as we increase in technological
understanding
and ability
we become more
technological we start seeing animals
like
elephants and giraffes and
big cats
we start seeing those as
like our children that we have to take
care of those species
so
you might keep some originals around
but what if you do something through
genetic engineering called elevation
where you elevate a tiger by increasing
its intelligence making it more
human-like
and then have it like like a child
that lives in your house that you take
care of
you know you make a new species but it's
it's a lion
but it now can
have a greater role in human society
that's another option
i'm done with that yeah now it has
a human type intelligence maybe it's got
opposable thumbs it could walk upright
but it's still lying
and it could speak you know you know why
not maybe that's possible so you're
elevating the animals
instead of wiping them out or
worrying you know what i mean keeping
them in cages you're elevating them so
they can function in society
how about an idea like that i mean yeah
i'd be down with that
i mean i'm very willing to
accept
that animals even the way they are
i always kind of thought animals were a
lot smarter than humans gave them credit
for
i kind of feel like for a long time
humans were like oh we're the smartest
ever and it's like animals are dumb and
stuff like that but i was like well
they evolved uh for the same amount of
time that we did so obviously they can't
be that stupid because they're still
around
um it all depends on what
as i said ecological niche that they
were occupying
and they were exactly as intelligent as
they needed to be and
and also like people are overestimating
how intelligent humans are which is not
very but
i mean
when we since we've had pookie
pookie is
uh
like
she's basically like a human kid
okay she can't talk yeah
but facial expressions her facial
expressions and her
vocalizations like her tone
it's very very clear
what she's trying to get across i mean
she's very good at like communicating
you pretty much know exactly what she
wants you can tell what her mood is
from the way her face looks or from the
tone of her
vocalizations the things that she
says
you know are it's pretty clear from what
i thought from what i remember
here and
from the guys that had figured or
figured most of some of this out at
least through genetics
somebody might correct me if i'm wrong
but intelligence doesn't really have a
lot to do with speech
no
humans speak because there's a certain
gene packet that we have
and we have larynx for it
um
i mean if apes could talk if they had
that they don't have the mechanism well
yeah there's also some kind of gene
packet
inside the genome that allows
kind of like a certain ability kind of
like a mental ability but they couldn't
talk they would if they could they would
but it kind of like
it manif because of that certain gene
packet and manifests in childhood when
you're when it when when it's around
other things that talk
um if if you were to probably give that
gene packet to an ape or a
or uh or a cat and then give it a give
it a vocal cords
it would probably be able to talk
all right
uh if if
even even though without really
elevating it's really it's it's
intelligence too much it would be able
to talk
this it wouldn't have a whole lot to say
you know it's not that intelligent but
it would talk ask for things and
maybe try to put a sentence together
but it's just but it has more to do
with that gene then those genes then it
does the intelligence
because in a way birds are talking they
don't have very much intelligence yeah
of course they are yeah
well and they have a whole
well the thing about it is that they
have a whole uh language that we don't
really understand because we don't live
in that culture we're not birds
so we don't really understand what
they're saying to each other so
it's possible that they could be
relating a whole bunch of like subtle
messages
but and i kind of suspect this is
probably the case
maybe that we don't
get
because we're not them it might just be
a bunch of emotion
yeah but
that's not i mean
we can't like denigrate him because of
that but i mean that's what humans do
yeah like i said humans aren't really
that much smarter
let's not get let's not get up ourselves
yeah you know what i'm saying
um
so what's that and like i said the fact
that
pookie kind of talks
she has like little vocalizations that
go like in a certain way that's kind of
sounds like human speech
and you kind of know what she wants
when she talks
and it's usually correct so she's pretty
good at like communicating what she
wants like through her facial
expressions through her vocalizations so
i don't think that's that's not dumb
that's not dumb at all and i kind of
feel like animals in general are
probably like way smarter than humans
give them credit for i've always thought
that
and i'm kind of glad nowadays to be like
sort of vindicated because
dan
uh i wanted to like back up because
somebody said something back here but i
can't remember where it was
how much have i missed says rebecca
probably like a lot probably like two
hours worth
but
start on 78 this was a while back this
is one of the ones i wanted to address
when i was in antarctica
he was in antarctica yeah starting
somebody gets in i used to feed this uh
skewer which is a bird about 10 years
later i saw i came back and a skewer
flew right up to me i swear it was the
same one and he recognized me not crazy
uh
birds actually do recognize human faces
so
i would not be surprised if that was the
same one and he was like hey bud
what's up yeah well the uh
the uh the cranes would recognize me
yeah we've talked about the sandhill
cranes before they will absolutely if
you get them a granola bar like one time
they will remember you forever yeah and
i think some of them that approached me
remembered me for when i fed them when
they were little when they were babies
because they grew up they grow up fast
yeah they grow up real fast a couple
months they're [ __ ] full grown
so you'll have a full-grown [ __ ]
crane walk up to you like he knows you
asking for food and i mean hey bud i'm
like remember that time you give him one
then
it might have been that little one that
was that big you know
a year ago yeah it's like i'm kind of
down on my luck right now i remember you
gave me something back in the days and
that's like yeah well yeah before you
know it they'll be like [ __ ] knocking
on your windows wanting to put food
um tila says i have to admit i've been
to tons of zoos and circuses i have as
well but
i don't have a problem with zoos per se
as long as their focus is
conservation
and as long as they're giving the
animals
a habitat that's similar to their
habitat in the wild and they're not like
confining them in the cages like i said
when i was a kid the zoo that i went to
there'd be like a big [ __ ] tiger and
he'd be like in a
cage like smaller than this room
which
that's [ __ ] up you shouldn't do that
to any [ __ ] animal
but if you're gonna have something where
you have like these big huge like
expansive areas
and it simulates their
you know uh
habitat in the wild
and they're endangered and also they're
kind of like doing something like they
have a breeding program or something
like that i don't have a problem with
that but
i kind of feel like the era of let's
just put all these exotic animals in
these tiny little [ __ ] horrible cages
with concrete and let people come and
gawk at them i kind of feel like that's
over and
rightfully so i really don't think that
we should be doing that
but
you know like i said if you have a
breeding program and you have like a
really good
area that
simulates their habitat in the wild then
i don't have a problem with it
um
let me see
yeah i hate zoos also i'm okay with
conservation reserves etc yeah
yeah i remember seeing a silverback in a
concrete jail as a four-year-old and i
cried my ass off yeah i mean i remember
being a kid and being at the zoo and
seeing this it was a tiger
and it was in this like really small
enclosure that was all like caged in and
i remember as a kid being like what
this poor like
and i was like little it's like i didn't
know like how much you know room these
animals needed but i was kind of like
this
i was like this is small it's like this
is smaller than my house and my house is
pretty small and it's like i don't think
a tiger should be living in like this
small of an area
uh kanavatsan says they say that
dolphins are next in line in
intelligence before humans
yeah it's hard to say they probably are
i mean it's hard to say because their
lifestyle is so different
but
i don't see what intelligence is i mean
great apes are like pretty but honestly
i don't really make much of a
distinction between
apes and huma i mean humans
from a technical standpoint are apes
we're just states so it's not like we're
making a big distinction between
us and chimpanzees and gorillas it's
like 98 dna similarity so it's like it's
not that much difference when you're
talking about something like dolphins
who are significantly
you know distant from us genetically but
not that different they're pretty far um
but i mean from
yeah they are but
not that far
so it's kind of like
i don't know so the intelligence is
different because their uh their
intelligence and their uh you know
lifestyle is so much different from ours
but they have a bunch of senses we don't
have from everything i could determine
about them they do really seem to i mean
they have a lot of the same things that
people equate with intelligence the
weird thing about it is that
we judge animal intelligence
by
human standards
which is dumb because
other intelligent animals are living in
an entirely
different uh you know kind of
environment to us
like if you're a dolphin
things that are on a human intelligence
test that's not going to be relevant
you know what i mean so it's like we're
the ones administering the tests
but the dolphins are just kind of like
well
that doesn't really mean anything to us
because that's not anything that has to
do with us
but
from our standpoint they seem very
intelligent to us in the sense that they
can
recognize themselves in mirrors uh they
seem to like have self-awareness
things like that so
you know
uh let's see
do do
do can you imagine dolphins binge
watching 10 hours of tiger king they're
way too smart for that
they probably are
that's why i'm saying i i'm very
comfortable saying dolphins are probably
smarter than most humans because did i
watch 10 hours of tiger king yes i did
um
but you know what i mean
uh kanavasan also says bunnies are the
[ __ ] my brother had a bunny farm
one male and a harem of females he
[ __ ] all day for years until he died
what a life more than 10 years oh yeah
[Laughter]
zack says i love how as this
conversation is going down i'm cuddling
with an elderly poodle
oh
and then tila says i love seeing those
animal and people reunited videos do you
remember that one like about the dude
with the
lot it was a lion right yeah it's a
pretty famous one dude the line the lion
runs up to it and hugs
yeah yeah oh my god that was like that
was amazing well
like the dude's face for a second
he was just i saw it
for a second he was like oh [ __ ] he's
going to eat me yeah but then he was
like the lion was like no man oh man i
remember you yeah and it was just like
it was so funny it was like it was
almost like two people or the dude
the dude that raised that gorilla and
the gorilla saw him
remember
and then fought and then hung out with
him and then he brought his wife and
then he then the gorilla brought his two
wives and they all hung out and then we
got in the boat and left the gorilla
followed him all the way upstream and
called at him and then hung out with him
the next day
yeah
he considered the gorilla considering
him to his dad
see that's so cool yeah
and honestly
i don't know i'm fascinated by great
apes for particularly and i've read a
lot of books about like i've read all
jane goodall's stuff and stuff like that
and she's hung out with a lot of apes
and i'm red gorilla
what the vanilla gorilla okay the
abdominal snowman yeah
yeah and i've read a lot of books about
yeah about um
you know people that studied uh
you know gorillas and stuff like that or
live with them for an extended period of
time
and
pretty much everybody i don't
pretty much everybody that's done that
they approach them as though they're
humans after a while
because like they pretty much
kind of act like humans like they're all
very distinctive personalities they all
have their own kind of little quirks
going on
and
you know some of them are cool some of
them are dicks
just kind of like interacting with
humans it really doesn't seem all that
different
and that's kind of fascinating to me
that's that's a very fascinating yeah
rebecca says dogs have masters cats have
staff yeah
pretty much
i don't know
i don't know if pookie considers us
staff
she kind of well
maybe she does no she thinks we're we're
a family
she thinks her mommy and daddy and but
she's like a she's like a toddler in the
sense that why are you guys not doing
what i want you to do like immediately
she's getting off into the brush
brushing face oh my god her ears perked
up she knows what brush means
that's what we have is your brush yeah
she's like brush brush yeah i told you
you have to spell it yeah
you have to spell it she took a hair
brushing hold like she's got yes my hair
brush i have like a white hair brush
that i brush my hair with
and she i kind of started like [ __ ]
around one day i was brushing my hair
and she kind of kind of came up and was
like what are you doing and i was like
look it's brush mommy's brushing hair
i'm brushing pookie's hair and then
she's like oh she liked it
and so
now every morning
as soon as i walk into that area
like the dressing room area where the
brush is
pookie's like
and she jumps up on the sink
brush
brush
and i'm just kind of like oh [ __ ] do i
have time to do this right now because
if you start doing it she won't want to
stop then you'll have to stand there for
like half an hour or more
because she will not she'll just be like
yeah you could do this all day that's
she's perfectly happy with you doing it
all day
and i don't have time for that but i do
try to do it some
but she's like she gets super excited
about it and like you both brush up
she wants you to like brush her face
but she keeps moving her head
because she gets so excited
so it's kind of like i'm trying to brush
this out of her face and she's like
and then i'm trying to like brush her
back because i'm trying to like get all
the hair out too she's not like super
furry because she's short hair but
she's kind of like this and like that
and i'm just like look would you just be
still
and then finally she'll be still and
she'll put her head against my chest
like that and just let me [ __ ] brush
her but
if you let her do that
she will do it like all [ __ ] day
and she's just like you just she never
gets sick of it ever
and then
i'll do it for like half an hour and
then then she'll be like okay i'm fine
and she'll jump down and go do something
else but then the second she hears me
over there doing something
she's back
she jumps up on the thing
brush brush brush and she like pats it
with her hand like come on come on come
on and i'm just like jesus i don't have
time for this right now but yeah
i mean i try but jesus christ nobody has
time to do that are you ready to she's
listening
yeah
the things i do for pokey well like i
said she's like our child in a lot of
ways so
uh they're talking about foodie guys oh
dave the animals
i watched
day of the animals
last week i watched the rift tracks
version though
i think i saw it when i was a kid
and i had like forgotten about it
and i'm into like 70s
disaster or nature run amok movies so
i really wanted to watch it so i watched
it on the riptrax version is actually
really funny
day of the animals
is
i love it because leslie nielsen is in
it
and leslie nielsen
plays
the biggest [ __ ] douche bag that
you've ever seen he's like [ __ ]
aggro and rapey and it's just kind of
like it's a whole thing
and
i was actually surprised because i had
never seen him in a role that extreme
before and so i was like laughing my ass
off that he was in that but the funniest
thing about this movie
you can tell that they really didn't
have that much money to show like animal
attacks or anything so it's like well
let's just have most of the movie have
be most of these people like just
walking through the mountains or
whatever and then like animals like
staring at them
like angrily
so it's like let's have a [ __ ] shot
of this owl looking kind of pissed off
or this puma looking kind of pissed off
that will like insert like looking at
these people
so you don't really see like a lot of
animal attacks let's put it like that
but the premise of the thing being like
the animals are all pissed off because
humans are like [ __ ] up the earth or
whatever
and all the animals are mad
but
mostly it's just like people walking and
whining
and
intercut with shots of animals looking
pissed off at them
but it's kind of hilarious
it's hilarious too in the sense that
like i said leslie nielsen is in it and
he is a giant
anus in this movie he is such a dick
i think he even like tries to rape a
girl
at
yeah
i haven't seen that a long time but
that's the one about the rats that's
based on the h.g wells story well
loosely based on the h2 wild story
camp guy says my dogs will piss on the
floor
just if they need to and i don't follow
their nighttime schedule of going out
right before bed
i mean you know yeah what was that pope
pookie doesn't do that she's actually
she's a good girl she's not like super
bratty no she will like share some stuff
up but
not like i've seen some other videos of
like cats on youtube that's like oh you
make me mad i'm like pooping your bed or
like pooping your shoes or like tear up
your christmas tree or like tear up all
your
like pull off all the toilet paper
pookie doesn't do that she doesn't do
that um if she's mad she'll kind of like
scratch on the side of my little uh
ottoman over there
to get attention
but or she'll knock something off she'll
like get up on the thing and like push
something off
but she doesn't really do anything more
destructive than that she's not super
destructive
but she knows that because she knows
we'll pay attention to her if she just
does a little thing
what you drinking jenny uh this is a
screwdriver
viking orange juice
church of the fine divine girl and you
are right
you ah sleepy why are you sleepy
because i'm sleepy
come on be fun yeah
never watch day the animals for some
reason it's not a great movie i have to
say
it's kind of like one of those
ones that
you know there was a big thing in the
70s where everybody was like kind of
these
as i said like the nature run of muck
movies
some of them were more fun because they
were more ridiculous like night of the
leapus about giant bunny rabbits all
right we'll see you tayla have a good
one bye
yeah
you gotta go after dinner
um
daily animals was
fun but it was kind of like
a lot of it was kind of boring like i
said a lot of it was just like people
walking through the wilderness like
complaining
intercut with
shots of animals looking
stern
you know what i mean like what are these
[ __ ] [ __ ] doing so it was
kind of like that but it's still watch
the riptrax version i'm pretty sure it's
on to be you can watch that
tila says an old friend of mine used to
paint her dog's nails
i couldn't stand seeing that
damn yeah i'm look
i don't know like if you're if your
animal if your pet
wants to wear clothes or if they like if
it's a hairless cat and they're cold and
they want some a sweater or something
like that fine
but
i'm not a big fan of like making your
pets do some [ __ ] that just you want and
that they're not happy about it you know
what i'm saying i wouldn't try to like
impose costumes on pookie even as cute
as it would be
i don't really want to like make her
do something that she doesn't really
want to do you know what i'm saying yeah
she's
pookie is independent
um
she's never like even if you pick her up
like sometimes tom picks her up and
she's kind of like yeah she's just like
putting up with it
but
i wouldn't like put clothes on or
anything like that like i said it would
be super cute i have thought about it
but
i don't think she would like it she'd be
like what the [ __ ] are you doing huh
jesus christ jesus christ
mike says tom just go to bed man yeah
you're really you're bumming everyone
out yeah
yeah come on tom you can hang in there
where is that testosterone going i can't
make it
bad you're good we'll see that's the
thing you go to the bar all day and then
like nobody's we're trying to have a
good time and like you're [ __ ] you
are you've already
expended all of your effort on the
schizophrenic girl no it was other [ __ ]
too
oh other [ __ ] story that was just a
story that i brought back
now we've been on for three oh other
stuff happened too yeah it's not three
hours
later
i can barely hang on i've been off for
three hours
i'll see you guys all right well i guess
the show's over even though i'm still
having a good time but okay
i have to cut the hair on some breeds of
dogs because they don't shed yeah i mean
the thing about it is that
at least pookie has short hair
i brush her but
and
big things of hair come out i told her
the other day
because i was brushing her and like so
much hair came out that i was like i can
make a little tiny
like
uh like a little teddy pooky like a
little teddy bear like out of her hair
and that she could play with and i
thought that would be really funny but
that's like i don't really have the uh
expertise to do that
um if you have a green apple and apple
wake you up faster than caffeine solo
jenny show yeah well
you know
i mean
it's not as fun with him here
he was kind of in a cranky mood when he
was here
earlier i kind of feel like it was going
to go like this so
cause he's been at the bar all day i
don't know about the schizophrenic girl
until like we got until he just like
talked about the show
have i seen the sharon stone movie
sliver
yes but i don't
remember a goddamn thing about it
i don't remember a goddamn thing about
it so
you'll have to kind of like remind me
no more biker bar jetty
he can go i don't care i'm not gonna go
there but
yeah
he's been he left
at
what time did he leave
it was before
two that's for sure no it was before one
i think he left like 12 30 because i had
to do like a phone meeting with somebody
like about a graphic design job that i
had it too and it was he had left like a
long time before that so i think he left
like 1 30 and he didn't get back to lake
ford so he was there for like three
hours so he was there for three
hours camp guy said my cats have a
heated pad and heated water bowl in the
winter
they're outside the rest of the time my
wife had some occasionally but that's it
honestly um
i don't know the house we used to live
we let the cats out i wasn't happy about
it um
i don't especially we live in florida
there's a lot of there's gators there's
owls there's all kind of like you know
there's bears there's all kind of
animals that could eat a cat and i'm not
super happy about letting them run
around outside
but you know they're cats and they
really do like to go outside and like
you know chase moles or whatever so at
the old house we let them do it even
though it you know gave me stress every
time we did it
um
but
i kind of feel like it's better to
depending on where you are to keep them
inside yes they do get bored but you
have to
i mean i've tried to like really i try
to like keep her entertained you know
what i mean i try to
have all kind of stuff i have all kind
of toys around i have all kind of food
around i have all kind of like a brush
or i do kind of stuff and play with her
so
i want her to like not get bored because
i don't want to really go outside
uh beijing will still go outside
she won't go far but she'll go kind of
farter under the back porch and then
come back in
pookie will kind of go outside for a
second and then she'll be like no [ __ ]
it i'm coming back in because she's
scared of the dogs next door
and to be honest i'm fine with that i
don't really like
especially where we live now which is
really rural
and
our yard i mean where we used to live
was
suburban
and there was a there was other houses
like really close by everybody's bushes
and like the cats could go hide in other
people's you know the neighbors bushes
or whatever and it was probably
[Music]
they probably weren't gonna
you know get [ __ ] up by an animal
because
there was a lot of like you know houses
really close to each other
this neighborhood
there's a lot of houses but they're very
very far apart
and our yard in particular
i mean we planted some hedges around the
outside but they haven't grown in yet
it's going to take a year or two before
they grow in
you know at the property line
so our shit's like all open
and
there's a lot of there's bears there's
eagles there's
alligators there's like all kind of
stuff around here and i'm just like
really not
comfortable with her running around like
in the open
so
i'm kind of glad that she
is
scared of the dogs next door so it won't
go outside so basically she just like
stays up here
um she goes downstairs sometimes and
steals beijing's food
because beijing's little bowl is down in
the kitchen and pookie's bowl is up here
but pookie will absolutely go down and
like eat beijing's food
that's why she's kind of getting like a
little
a little chubby but that's okay
but yeah so there's that and uh but
she's not really into outside she'll go
out on the back porch for a second but
then she's like nah [ __ ] it and she just
comes back in
beijing will go out but not that far
cats can climb fence yeah that's what
i'm saying well pookie used to at our
old house
we had like a backyard and then there
was like a it wasn't even a fence it was
like a well it's kind of a fence but it
was solid but she figured out how to
crawl under it
and behind the fence was a like the
county path and there was like a like
and then there was like a road but it
was farther away so sometimes she would
crawl under that
and she would sit by the path and like
watch
people or bears or whatever like going
by so there was that but
since we've moved here she seems to have
lost interest in going outside she still
jumps up on the
uh you know the windowsills and like
looks out the windows
but
she doesn't really
she doesn't try to like escape like she
used to i think she's like afraid of the
outside here because it's too big and
open
um which like i said is fine with me i'd
rather she stay inside
i'm like i got like really paranoid
about her so it's kind of like
even in the middle if i a lot of times
like i'll wake up in the middle of the
night because i have to go to the
bathroom and then like
i'll be like i wonder what pookie is
so when i get up to the bathroom i look
for her
and then like if i don't see her like
i'll get back in bed and i'll
and i'll do this like i'll pat on my
chest and then like she'll run up
she runs up like my body is like right
here right here i'm like okay i was just
checking she knows that i check on her
in the middle of the night
uh rebecca's talking about the prestige
that was a great movie honestly i've
been trying to like do a
review on that for a really long time i
love that [ __ ] movie the book's good
too the book's a lot different
than the movie like
the story's not different but the
the focus of it is different i feel like
but
i really liked the book also but in it
in a different way but the movie is
amazing
also do you guys remember
that the same was it the same year that
the prestige came out there was another
movie that came out called the
illusionist
and it was like
almost the same story
kind of i feel like but i haven't seen
in a long time and i was kind of like
that's weird that like two things came
out at the same time but i don't know if
you guys have seen the illusionist the
prestige is a lot better but
you know one of these days we'll do a
review of it
uh tammy says my cats are inside and
outside counts but only because they're
both strays and they usually just follow
me around my gardens when we're outside
yeah i mean like i said at the old house
i kind of feel like the cats
wanted to go outside more because there
was more
uh the neighbors houses were really
close and they also had bushes and stuff
like that they could hide in they
explore
here it's kind of like big and open and
i think they're kind of like freaked out
by it which like i said is kind of fine
with me because i would rather they stay
in
um
jenny did you hear that chris stuckman
made a kickstarter for his name yeah i
saw that um i watched the video where he
talked about
when i saw the video i think he'd made
like 800 000 so he was like pushing
toward a million but i saw later that he
had made over a million so
that makes me really happy because you
know what chris duckman
if you uh haven't watched his channel he
just seems like a really nice dude and
he's a filmmaker he's a movie reviewer
but he makes films also
and he's really really into film and
that makes me really really happy that
um and he seemed really happy about it
he's like really humble and happy about
it so i thought that was really cool but
when i saw that video i think he'd made
like 800 something thousand
and you know so they're gonna make a
movie so we'll see if it's good i hope
it's good
love the prestige i did and camp guy
also mentioned the illusionist yeah and
i
had kind of forgotten about it but then
i saw
i was on some streaming service the
other day and i saw the illusionist on
there i'm like oh yeah i remember that
came out like almost exactly the same
time as the prestige uh to the point
where it seemed like it was almost like
a rip-off but like i said i know the
prestige was like based on a novel who
wrote that novel christopher priest his
last name was priest christopher priest
i want to say his name was and i read
the book my brother gave it to me i
remember that
and uh yeah the book is really good too
but it's different from the movie so
don't go into the book like think it's
gonna be the same as a movie it's the
same story
but
it's the approach of it is a lot
different but it's still good
um
yeah but yeah i love the [ __ ]
prestige
uh i can see jenny and all four of the
main female characters in yellowjackets
it's such a good show see i need to
watch this now
make a screenplay with tom as an actor
in a supernatural movie it could work
yeah you know
yeah the illusionist had edward norton
yeah yeah that's right
i mean
i would really actually like to watch
the illusionist again because i think i
only saw it once the prestige i've seen
like three or four or five times
and i've read the book too
the illusionist
i remember seeing it once but then being
like wait was this made to like
capitalize on the prestige coming out
because it's kind of similar but it's
not
that similar
i think it was just kind of one of those
things where
it was kind of in the zeitgeist that
we're all doing stories about
magicians at the moment and that it just
kind of happened but yeah so there might
have been that
all right so
i guess
we've been on long enough
nobody just wants to listen to me
prattle around tom took off and it's
probably sleeping at this point
even though i'm gonna have to go like
[ __ ] forge some food or something
like that because i'm kind of
i ate but it was like a long time ago
probably like nine hours ago
uh but yeah so thanks everybody for
hanging out with us this
friday evening
and we will be back on sunday talking
about
whatever movie we watch tomorrow which i
don't know what it will be but it'll be
something good i hope
and uh so yeah thanks for dropping by
everybody thanks for super chats
and
we will see you guys on sunday
afternoon bye